Wir machen das so sehr professionell mit Opener. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio, dem unterhaltsamen Live-Talk Radio Klassiker, wie ich gerade erfahren habe, aus Berlin, der seit 1995 über wechselnde Themen berühmt um Technologie und Gesellschaft informiert und der traditionsgemäß eigentlich zum Chaos Communication Congress ausfällt, weil man hat ja genug zu tun. Der Club baut Dinge auf, Dinge ab, macht Vorträge etc. Aber dieses Mal, aufgrund dessen, dass es jetzt wiederholt mal auch ein Sendezentrum gab und die ganze Technik, also was man hier so sieht, ist zum großen Teil auch das, was man im Chaosradio hören kann. Da haben wir gesagt, nein, so ein Chaosradio, das kann man vielleicht auch mal auf dem Kongress machen. Das bietet sich ja quasi an und jetzt mit Nummer 230 haben wir es tatsächlich geschafft. Allerdings muss ich auch dazu sagen, falls die Sendung heute anders klingt als sonst, liegt das auch daran, dass es ein Kongress ist, weil eigentlich jeder, den ich gefragt habe, also machen wir das jetzt oder sollen wir jetzt, ist eine gute Idee, ja, und dann Tag 4 ist man auch so ein bisschen durch und wir machen auch heute nicht ein Thema, sondern vier und die Leute müssen auch während der Sendung kommen, weiß ich nicht so genau, ob das klappt, vielleicht machen wir Nerd News, vielleicht nicht, wer weiß, aber wir geben unser Bestes. Und außerdem machen wir heute, wie drücke ich das jetzt möglichst gut aus, wir machen was aus dem Kapitel nachhaltige Berichterstattung, wir machen jetzt nicht die großen Themen, also Fintech-Unternehmen gehackt, Interplanetare Raumfahrt, russische Hacker, sondern wir machen Dinge, die immer mal wieder aufgetaucht sind und die auch dieses Jahr wieder eine Rolle spielen und auch immer wieder spielen sollten und da so eine Themen auch dazu tendieren, dann irgendwie so vielleicht vergessen zu werden, nach dem geben wir heute nochmal eine Bühne. Und damit begrüße ich auch schon die erste Gästin, Maria Reimer, hallo und guten Tag. Guten Morgen. Bist du noch bei Bewusstsein?
Ich bin anwesend, physisch, geistig würde sich das rausstellen, es ist auch für mich Tag 4, aber ich freue mich sehr über die Einladung.
Schauen wir mal. Du warst schon mal hier, und zwar am 29. November 2014. Da haben wir zum ersten Mal über Jugendhackt gesprochen. Und das wollen wir heute im Prinzip auch tun, aber dann noch über ein großes Thema reden. Aber vielleicht mal ganz zum Anfang und auch, weil das vielleicht für dich ein bekanntes Torrent ist, wo du dich dann sozusagen geistig auch hierher bewegen kannst. Was ist denn Jugendhackt?
Das ist aber eine nette Einstiegsfrage. Der Elevator-Pitch. Jugendhackt ist ein gemeinnütziges Förderprogramm von zwei gemeinnützigen Vereinen gegründet, um junge Nerdinnen, Nerds und solche, die es werden wollen, miteinander in Kontakt zu bringen, ihnen eine technische Weiterentwicklung zu ermöglichen und mit dem stetigen Austausch darauf hinzuwirken, dass sie ihre technischen Fähigkeiten für gesellschaftliche Zwecke einsetzen und nicht nur, wie Fiona im letzten Chaos Radio zu dem Thema gesagt hat, die nächste Shopping-App zu programmieren.
Genau, das passiert in Form eines Hackathons, also hat es zumindest angefangen, Jugendliche zusammen zu kommen und Dinge miteinander zu machen. Die Anleitung ist eigentlich schon fast falsch. Also quasi mit Mentoren, die dabei sind, die man Sachen fragen kann, aber nicht muss.
Genau, das ist das klassische Format, das auch so die feste Säule von Jugendhack ist. Das sind Wochenendevents, die wie ein Hackathon funktionieren, am Ende keinen Wettbewerb mehr haben. Also es ist sozusagen auf Jugendliche und deren individuelle Lernkurve adaptiert. Das ist nicht so der klassische Axelspringer Hackathon oder so, sondern das ist halt so ein bisschen auf Jugendliche einfach adaptiert. Die müssen halt auch irgendwann schlafen und so. Und im Zentrum steht aber tatsächlich deren selbstbestimmte Entwicklung einer eigenen Idee, die sie halt an dem Wochenende prototypisch umsetzen.
Und als wir im November 2014 darüber geredet haben, da gab es, glaube ich, genau eine Veranstaltung. Also ihr habt das sozusagen einmal im Jahr gemacht. Ich bin irgendwann dem Twitter-Account gefolgt. Jetzt ist es gefühlt jedes Wochenende eine Veranstaltung. Das ist ein bisschen für dramaturgische Zwecke übertrieben. Aber es passiert schon viel mehr. Und das am weitesten weg Event, was ich gesehen habe, war Südkorea.
Ja, das war ganz cool. Also wir sind tatsächlich im November 2016 auf Einladung des Goethe-Instituts mit Mitteln des Auswärtigen Amtes nach Südkorea geflogen, um dort uns mit südkoreanischen Jugendlichen zusammen Gedanken zum Schüleraustausch der Zukunft zu machen. Und das war nett, weil es generell toll ist, eine Dienstreise nach Südkorea zu machen. Und weil das eine nette Klassenfahrt war mit zehn Jugendlichen, vier Mentoren, Mentoren und drei Organisatoren. Wir waren sozusagen 17 aus der deutschen Delegation und sind dann auf das Äquivalent in Südkorea getroffen. Du hast vorhin gefragt, was ist seit dem letzten Chaosradio passiert, was ist in den letzten zwei Jahren passiert. Beim letzten Chaosradio haben wir glaube ich noch ganz viel darüber geredet, wie Gesellschaftshackertum eigentlich noch um Akzeptanz ringt. Zwei Jahre später werden wir quasi als Exportgut deutscher Kultur nach Südkorea geflogen und der deutsche Botschafter begrüßt uns bei der Abschlusspräsentation und sagt, es liegt in eurer Hand auch was gegen den Populismus zu tun. Bezieht sich gar nicht auf den Umgang so viel mit Technologie, sondern hat das schon längst abstrahiert, dass das natürlich auch demokratische Anschlusspunkte hat, was den Jugendtag so tut.
Es wird also nicht nur immer größer, es gibt ja auch in Deutschland mittlerweile mehrere Jugendtag-Events in Österreich und Schweiz, es wird also nicht nur größer und bekannter, sondern es gibt auch mehr Verantwortung, die man auferlegt bekommt. Und die habt ihr auch versucht, in einer anderen Form wahrzunehmen, so hab ich es zumindest gesehen, ich hab hier einen Vortrag gehalten über Anerkennungskultur. Das finde ich ganz spannend, weil ich finde, das hängt ein bisschen damit zusammen, was der Communication Congress auch seit einer Weile versucht. Also was ich finde, was so ein bisschen mitschwingt, was auch in dem Motto dieses Jahr drinsteckt, das Motto ist ja Works for me, was so ein abfälliges Programmierer-Ding ist, wenn man seinen Fehler berichtet und sagt, hey, das ist mein Kunden, also nö, bei mir funktioniert's, bitte geh mal woanders hin. Quasi die Art und Weise, wie man, also als jemand, der Auskennner ist, kommuniziert. Und das habt ihr in dem Vortrag auch versucht zu beleuchten, dieses, okay, also wir machen was für Jugendliche, die, und da ist ja gefühlt, da war ja erst mal sozusagen so eine Stufe drin, also Experten, vielleicht nicht mal die technischen, aber wenigstens sozusagen die im Pädagogischen und so was, da habt ihr so eine Reflektionsebene eingebaut. Und also Einstiegsfrage ist, ihr habt ja die Mentoren, die da mitmachen, die kommen ja, sind ja die klassischen Nerds, wenn man so will, also quasi Leute, die sich auskennen und dann sagen, so was Gutes. Und Anerkennungskultur ist nichts, was man jetzt vom Klischee her mit solchen Menschen und mit dieser Bubble sozusagen verbindet. War das ein Problem? Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden. Also wenn man das negative Klischee bedient und man zu einem Nerd kommt und sagt so, erklär mal, dann macht er so, ja, du musst dir einfach den Fronkulator kompulieren und dann ist natürlich klar, dass du in dem Gate 11 auch noch den Buffer Overflow verpumpeln musst und so.
Und Render nicht vergessen.
Und Render nicht vergessen, Becker auch. Und da ist natürlich die Frage, gab das da Probleme in der Zusammenarbeit zwischen Leuten, die Technik machen, aber guten Willens sind und Jugendlichen?
Jetzt habe ich deine Frage verstanden und es ist eine gute. Das ist wirklich eine gute und interessante Frage, weil sie ja eigentlich die Frage ist nach der Motivation. Warum schlagen sich Erwachsene ehrenamtlich ein Wochenende mit Jugendlichen um die Ohren, die ihnen einem Schwamm gleich alles aus dem Hirn ziehen und sie danach denken, scheiße, in 10 Jahren brauche ich einen neuen Job, weil die, die nachkommen, so viel besser und schneller sind als ich, weil sie das Internet hatten und ich hatte nichts. Also warum tut man das überhaupt? Ich habe sowieso Probleme mit diesem Nerd-EV. Ich glaube nicht an dieses homogene Bild eines Nerds in einem Stereotyp vereint. Ich glaube, da gibt es einfach so viele unterschiedliche Menschen, wie es halt Menschen sind. Und die, die aber zu Jugendhack kommen, haben, glaube ich, eine starke Identifikation mit diesem Gefühl, wie es ist, in einer Pubertät zu sein und zu merken, boah, ich habe eigentlich ein viel krasseres technisches Interesse, vielleicht auch Wissen, als die anderen Kinder. Ich habe aber überhaupt niemanden, mit dem ich auf Augenhöhe reden kann. Und in den Medien werde ich nach wie vor als asozial dargestellt, also irgendwie gesellschaftsfeindlich oder inkompatibel. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein starker Motivator, was diese erwachsene Nerds dazu bringt, bei Jugendhack sozusagen mitzumachen. Und eine zweite Komponente ist aber glaube ich auch, dass das schon Menschen sind, die Interesse haben an anderen Menschen, also grundsätzlich auch Menschenfreunde sind, was man eben haben muss. Also es gibt ja auch gerade in diesem Feld ziemlich viele introvertierte Menschen. Und du musst ja in gewisser Weise doch bereit sein, über deinen Schatten zu springen und auch andere Menschen anzusprechen, proaktiv, wenn du eine gute Mentorin oder ein guter Mentor sein willst. Und ich glaube, diese Vorgabe ist sozusagen schon erfüllt. Also die Mentoren sind auch teilweise super eingeschüchtert, wenn sie kommen, aber einfach weil die Jugendlichen sie glaube ich so einschüchtern. Und weil es dasselbe Phänomen ist, was wir auch unter den Jugendlichen sehen. Also du bist im Alltag, wenn mal gerade nicht Kongress ist oder so, bist du ja eine Minderheit mit deinen Hobbys oder mit deiner Inselbegabung oder deiner Neigung. Also im Zweifelsfall kannst du dich halt mit niemanden über Protokolle unterhalten oder es versteht auch niemand, warum so basale Sachen, warum halt WhatsApp irgendwie nicht so eine geile Idee ist. Und dann kommen diese Menschen, egal ob Erwachsene oder Jugendliche, zu Jugendhackt und sehen, es gibt Hunderte, die sind genauso wie ich. Und das ist natürlich erleichternd, weil man endlich eine Peer Group hat, aber es nimmt einem auch was vom eigenen Besonderen weg. Also vielleicht...
Ist es dann so, dass man denkt, dass es dann so kippt von, okay, hier sind Leute wie ich, dass man dann wiederum sagt, okay, jetzt muss ich mich aber auch beweisen. Also jetzt muss ich auch zeigen, dass ich der geilste Hacker oder die geilste Hackerin aller Zeiten bin.
Ja, könnte man annehmen, ne?
Und steht da so ein Konkurrenzding auch?
Ne, gar nicht, weil wir, also zumindest mittlerweile nicht mehr, also wir haben zumindest für unsere letzte Berliner Veranstaltung am Ende keine Preisverleihung mehr gehabt. Das heißt, es gab schon gar kein Wettrennen der entstehenden Projekte um eine besondere Anerkennung mehr. Also sozusagen dieses Ende wurde schon mal weggenommen.
Warum? Es ging ja um Anerkennungskultur, da kann man sagen, die beste Anerkennung ist natürlich, wenn ich sage, du hast das geilste Projekt dieses Hackathons gemacht.
Und du und du und du nicht. Du bist cool, du nicht so. Also das ist ja auch, was ein Wettbewerb sagt. Wir haben einfach gemerkt, über Jahre, das zahlt halt nicht auf unsere Ziele ein. Also das Ziel von Jugendhack ist, diese individuellen Lernkurven zu ermöglichen, was halt an Schulen auch nicht funktioniert, insbesondere nicht in diesem technischen Feld, weil wenn es Informatikunterricht gibt, sind wahrscheinlich 105 Prozent aller Jugendlichen von Jugendhack dort unterfordert. Frage vergessen.
Also es gibt jetzt nicht mehr diesen Wettbewerb, weil da gibt es zwar die Auszeichnung, aber auch an alle, die nicht ausgezeichnet wurden, die das ebenso deutlich bemerken. Was ist die Alternative?
Na, es sind genau zwei Sachen passiert. Also wir haben jetzt gesagt, der Wettbewerb zahlt nicht auf unsere Ziele ein, weil der eigentlich ein Produkt belohnt, aber wir sind eigentlich an den Prozess interessiert und kommunizieren das auch so. Der Weg ist, das Ziel ist glaube ich sehr nah am Hackertum. Also man muss halt immer wieder einen neuen Fehler finden, einen neuen Fehler und von so einem Endprodukt auszugehen, treibt einen glaube ich eher in den Wahnsinn, als sich das nächste Ding vorzunehmen, den nächsten one bug at a time. Und parallel haben wir zum ersten Mal was ausprobiert mit Badges, also das sind so wie Achievements in Games. Das funktionierte so, wir hatten so, wir haben das erstmal physisch ausprobiert, halt auf so Pubkarten haben wir Kategorien geschrieben, sowas wie helfende Hand oder Open Data Königin oder Open Sourceheld und immer wenn ein Mentor etwas bei einem Jugendlichen gesehen hat, dass er so anerkennungswürdig fand, also ein Verhalten, was gewünscht ist und man verstärken wollte, hat man halt dem Jugendlichen so einen Badge überreicht.
Die Angst oder Kritik an so Gamification Systemen oder Achievement Systemen ist ja auch, dass sie dann gegamed werden im Sinne von, ok, es gibt also ein Open Source Ding und ich helfe jetzt einmal, dann habe ich das Achievement. Hatte das auch diesen Effekt?
Na dazu haben wir gerade noch zu wenig Datenpunkte. Wir haben das erst einmal ausprobiert und es ist alles so alpha. Und wir haben das mit den Mentoren sehr intensiv diskutiert, bevor wir das einführen wollten. Das war jetzt nicht so eine Top-Down-Geschichte, sondern wir haben das so zur Diskussion gestellt, wie die Mentoren das finden, ob das auch deren Kritik irgendwie inkorporiert und ein guter neuer Vorschlag ist, wie man eben Lernprozesse abbilden kann. Und klar, das war eine Befürchtung, dass dann Leute anfangen, einfach zu sammeln, weil wir irgendwie Sammler sind. Aber das hat sich so nicht bewahrheitet und ich glaube, so einfach, das ist ja kein, das ist nicht so ein maschinelles System, sondern du hast ja eine menschliche Komponente. Also du musst, indem du einmal eine Flasche von A nach B getragen hast, musst du erstmal gesehen werden. Also so dieses, ich werde gesehen und das wird belohnt. Und wenn du es halt so machst, wie du gerade vorgemacht hast, dann kauft dir halt keiner ab, dass das intrinsisch ist.
Noch zwei Fragen. Die eine ist, ihr habt das auch bei dem Event gesagt, das spielt in der Anerkennungskultur auch eine Rolle, weil quasi so ein bisschen Transparenz, das heißt auch Fehlerkultur, damit offen umging. Was habt ihr falsch gemacht? Also gibt es etwas, wo ihr wirklich gesagt habt, okay, es gibt die eine Sache, die haben wir falsch gemacht und die sehen wir tatsächlich auch nur, weil wir uns vornehmen, das zu reflektieren.
Also wir haben ganz viele Sachen, machen wir bestimmt falsch, weil alles andere wäre irre anzunehmen. Aber eine Sache, die uns dieses Jahr richtig aufgegangen ist, ist, dass wir in unserer Kommunikation an die Erwachsenen, also eigentlich nur an die mittelbare Zielgruppe von Jugendhackt immer war so, hey, du bist ein Techie, du hast irgendwie Lust, deine Fähigkeiten so weiterzugeben, ohne Lehrer zu sein. Und du kannst dich grob mit dem Konzept von Jugendlichen anfreunden, so dann komm doch zu uns. Und mit dieser Kommunikation haben wir halt auf so eine Mitte von reinen Techies abgezielt. Und die ganzen Ränder, also Menschen, die auch sich in dieser Szene bewegen, aber jetzt nicht die harten Techies sind, aber dafür, weiß ich nicht, mega gute Moderatoren sind oder, weiß ich nicht, ihr Ferienjob war, eine Rezeption in einem Hotel zu leiten und deswegen total gute Empfangspersonen für das Event sind. Also es gibt super viele Rollen außerhalb dieser harten, technischen Mentorengeschichte. Und das haben wir komplett vergessen, explizit zu machen. Also alle, die bei Jugendhackt als Erwachsene dabei sind, deine Co-Moderatorin, also Marcus hat dieses Jahr Jugendhackt auch in der DERB-Flussveranstaltung moderiert. Nicht erst dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal, sondern zum zweiten Mal. Und Marcus hat das dieses Jahr zusammen mit Miriam Seifert gemacht, eine Zoom, die wer sie kennt, zu Recht mega großartig findet. Und das ist nur entstanden, dass sie dort moderiert hat, weil ich persönlich mit ihr befreundet bin. Und sie deswegen über Jugendhack gehört hat. Aber sie wäre von selber nie auf die Idee gekommen, dass das was für sie ist.
Weil die Ansprache von euch zu technisch war?
Ja, genau. Riesen Fail unsererseits.
Das ist die eine Sache. Das führt mich direkt zur zweiten Frage, die ich noch stellen wollte. Weil ich das übertragen möchte auf alles, was hier vom Kongress passiert. Wenn sich Leute zusammenfinden, um so eine Technik Sache zu machen, dass man oft das Gefühl hat, es geht genau nur um die Technik. Und der ganze Rest wird vergessen. Was einerseits dazu führt, dass man nur Leute hat, die sich hart an der Technik interessieren und dann vielleicht gar nicht so ein gemischtes Team kriegt, was es noch mal andere Einblicke gibt. Das andere ist, dass man auch über seine Kommunikation anscheinend oder vielleicht so unnötig eskaliert, dass ich kenne das, dass wenn in solchen Gruppen Probleme dann auftreten, dass dann total hart und manchmal sogar feindselig diskutiert wird, anscheinend, weil es diese Reflektionsebene gibt, die ihr ja eingezogen habt. Und das würde ich jetzt zum Abschlussvon dir gerne haben wollen. Es gibt da draußen noch mehr Leute, die Dinge tun, die mit Technik zu tun haben und Menschen, die zusammenkommen. Wie habt ihr diesen Prozess etabliert? Was würde es anderen empfehlen? Wie viel Zeit sollte man dafür einrechnen, dass man sagt, wir müssen auch immer wieder auf uns selber gucken? Und wie macht man das am besten, ohne dass es so etwas ganz Leeres und Zwanghaftes bekommt?
Du stellst so große Fragen, Marcus.
Das ist das Chaosradio. Wir müssen das Weltproblem klären.
Ich glaube, eine der Antworten, die Antwort birgt schon eine Schwierigkeit in sich. Die Antwort ist, dass man sich bewusst sein muss, dass Menschen grundsätzlich anders funktionieren als Maschinen. Das ist einfacher, aber auch schwer. Von menschlichen Gruppen und den damit einhergehenden sozialen Prozessen nicht zu verlangen, dass es eine Form von formalisierten Input-Output gibt. Du gibst immer dasselbe ein, du bekommst immer dasselbe zurück. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich kann dich anlächeln und du gibst mir ein Lächeln zurück. Ich kann jemand anders anlächeln und es passiert gar nichts. Es ist nicht das, was ich eingebe. Ich gebe immer dasselbe zurück. Ich glaube, das ist bei Community-Arbeit wichtig, sich auf die Mühe der Ebene zu nehmen, dass menschliche Interaktionen kompliziert sind und Zeitkosten und auch eine andere Herangehensweise erfordern. Als ich das in meinem beruflichen Alltag als Programmiererin oder Programmierer habe, ist es berufsimmanent, Fehler zu finden. Fehler sind teuer und machen, dass Dinge nicht funktionieren. Manchmal werden Diskussionen hart geführt. Manchmal gucke ich mir das von außen an und denke, das ist die Berufskrankheit, Fehler zu finden und auf diese Fehlerbehebung abzustellen. Statt zu sehen, wir haben gerade eine Gruppe von fünf Leuten, die Vibes waren noch total gut, und dann sind wir abgedriftet auf diesen einen Fehler oder diese eine Lücke.
Kann man das formalisieren, wenn man sich das vorher vornimmt? Wir machen jetzt zusammen Sachen, wir wollen auch auf uns achten.
Ja klar, das hilft. Andere nennen es Code of Conduct. Der Kongress hat einen sehr kurzen Code of Conduct mit be excellent to each other, aber klar hilft das, weil das deutlich macht, unter welchen sozialen Bedingungen man sich treffen möchte.
Gut, das heißt, wir fassen die halbe Stunde so zusammen. Be excellent to each other. Ich finde es schon spannend, weil auch so ein Code of Conduct klingt ja immer so ein bisschen wie sagen jetzt euch, wie ihr euch excellent zu verhalten. Ich glaube der Punkt ist, dass man immer auch an sich selber denkt. Das ist vielleicht auch eine Schwierigkeit, wenn man mit Menschen arbeitet, oder?
Na klar, das ist total schwierig zu sehen, was man alles nicht sieht. Ich könnte jetzt den Eindruck gewinnen, dass wir hier gerade eine nette halbe Stunde geplaudert haben, aber ich habe eigentlich keine Informationen von den Rändern meiner Wahrnehmung, die sein könnten, dass da hinten gerade eben 20 Leute aufgestanden sind, weil ich halt immer zu dir geguckt habe. Ist jetzt ein hypothetisches Beispiel, aber so dieses zu sehen, wo man Lücken hat, ist halt sehr schwierig, weil sich das gegenseitig ausschließt. Aber das zu trainieren, das kann man tun. So ist halt auch, glaube ich, so soziales Handwerk.
Kann man sich ja auch mal ab und zu sagen, wie der dran erinnert, dass man es machen muss. Wie geht es weiter mit Jugendhackt?
2017 ist auch für uns ein neues Jahr. Und es wird weiterhin hoffentlich viele und mehr noch Jugendhackts geben. Na klar, beschäftigt uns die Bundestagswahl nächstes Jahr. Das war jetzt kein Quark. Der deutsche Botschafter in Seoul hat eben gesagt, in Deutschland wird nächstes Jahr gewählt. Es liegt an euch. Und da reden wir noch gar nicht darüber, was passiert, wenn Rechtspopulisten auf einmal Zugang zu Datenbanken haben, die eigentlich innerhalb von einem gemäßigten Spektrum nur funktionieren. Und das wird uns einfach thematisch beschäftigen. Also wie machen wir unsere demokratischen Institutionen bis September noch wetterfest?
Aber es wird Jugendhack geben? Gut, dann ist ja auch eine Nachricht.
Ja klar, ne, wir gehen schon nicht mehr weg.
Alles klar, sehr schön. Maria Reimer, war das von Jugendhackt hier beim Chaosradio 230 zu Gast.
Vielen Dank.
So, dann hören wir jetzt eine kleine Musik. Die Musiken heute kommen aus der aktuellen Chillhop-Veröffentlichung für den Winter 2016 und Lovely Retail ist der erste Song. Danach geht es gleich weiter mit ein bisschen Populismus. So, lovely Rita Avadas von Birocratic, hier im Chaosradio 230 live vom Chaos Communication Congress, wo wir heute uns in nachhaltiger Berichterstattung üben, sozusagen mit Menschen reden, die Themen bringen, die nicht ganz neu sind, aber trotzdem relevant. Jetzt herzlich willkommen Martin Haase.
Hallo.
Das ist insofern ganz lustig, weil die im Vorfeld des Chaos Communication Congress wurde gesagt und berichtet. Es gibt so ein bisschen mehr politische Berichterstattung. Und erstmals ist unter anderem auch der Sprachwissenschaftler Martin Haase zu Gast und hält einen Vortrag über Sprache, habe ich gelesen.
Kontrafaktisch.
Moment mal, das kann mir ein bisschen komisch vor. Du bist schon eine Weile hier auf dem Chaos Congress. Dein Thema ist Neusprech.
Genau, und das Thema in verschiedenen Variationen habe ich schon seit 2008 bearbeitet, wie wir gerade nachgerechnet haben.
Also zum ersten Mal 2016 auf der Bühne, also Martin Haase mit Neusprech.
Naja, es war schon ein anderer Aspekt.
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Ich finde es nämlich tatsächlich nicht unspannend, aber für die wenigen, die dich noch nicht kennen, so ganz kurz in einer Minute dieses Neusprechding, was ist das grundsätzliche Thema, was sich da umtreibt?
Na ja, es geht um Politikersprache. Also wir sprechen Politiker und das war diesmal vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen was anderes, klar. Und ja, also es geht um die Möglichkeiten, dass eben Sprache auch manipulativ eingesetzt wird und dass man eben auf diese Weise, also nebel verbreiten kann und Leute eben dazu bewegen kann, Dinge zu tun.
Es gibt ja auch ein Chaosradio, das wir mal zusammen gemacht haben, da ging es eigentlich um die, wie man über Atomen, also über Risiken und Nebenwirkungen von Atomen kommuniziert. Da war das auch so der Fall. Was ist denn, wenn du mal die letzten Jahre zusammenfasst, gibt es da eine Entwicklung?
Na ja, es gibt überraschenderweise immer wieder was Neues. Das ist der Punkt. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass es eine Entwicklung gibt. Also wir hatten diese ganze Phase mit der Beschönigung relativ so am Anfang. Das war ja das Thema 2008. Dann kam Ursula von der Leyen.
Da geht es jetzt immer sozusagen um dieses Überwachungsding.
Genau, mit ihrer besonderen Leyen-Rhetorik, die dann immer sprachlich aufgerüstet hat. Und das erleben wir jetzt eigentlich wieder bei den Rechtspopulisten, die ja auch auf der einen Seite aufrüsten und auf der anderen Seite aber auch so in den Mainstream kommen wollen und dann wieder abrüsten. Also ich glaube, es gibt so ein Hin und Her zwischen Tendenzen der sprachlichen Aufrüstung, also eher so Dysphemismen-Verwendung und so. Und wie gesagt, bei von der Leyen war das ganz deutlich. Und dann gibt es wieder das Gegenteil, sogar bei derselben Person. Also jetzt, wo von der Leyen Verteidigungsministerin ist, hat sie sich eine andere Strategie überlegt oder sie hat sich jetzt einen anderen Redenschrei.
Genau, du hast dieses Jahr einen Vortrag gehalten über genau die sprachlichen Mittel der Populisten oder der Rechtspopulisten. Lass es mich mal einfach und populistisch fragen, wie machen die das?
Ja, wie machen die das?
Oder anders, warum verfängt das, was sie sagen?
Ich glaube, einer der wichtigsten Punkte ist diese semantische Offenheit, dass innerhalb der Gruppe Dinge was anderes bedeuten als sonst. Ich hatte ja in meinem Vortragsbeispiel Demokratie und Demokratie, da gibt es klare Definitionen, wie das definiert ist, da gehören gewisse Kriterien zu erfüllen, Minderheitenschutz dazu, wechselnde Mehrheiten und so und Demokratie in der Sprache der Rechtspopulisten heißt also immer mit der Aßtration wir sind das Volk, also jetzt geht es darum, dass wir die Rechtspopulisten jetzt auch mal Macht haben wollen, nur dann ist Demokratie gut und dann wird da immer noch von direkter Demokratie gesprochen und so, also das Volk, aber das soll dann immer heißen in unserer Gruppe, das soll jetzt mal bestimmt werden.
Aber das klingt so total offensichtlich, da würde man sich doch in den Kopf hauen und sagen, das ist doch Quatsch.
Naja, aber wenn es dann eine Kampagne gibt für mehr Demokratie aus dem rechten Spektrum, dann gibt es eben vielleicht immer Leute, die sagen, ja das klingt für mich plausibel.
Aber verfängt das dann wirklich nur bei den Leuten, die das gut finden? Also ist das sozusagen so ein Prozentsatz in der Gesellschaft, die eh rechts sind, wo es egal ist? Oder hast du nicht auch den Eindruck, dass diese populistische Sprache auch weiter verfängt?
Jaja, ich glaube, dass die weiter verfängt. Dass also diese unklaren Konzepte dann sich auch ausbreiten. Beziehungsweise, das ist jetzt noch eine andere Strategie, dass bestimmte Wortschöpfungen plötzlich weiterverwendet werden. Also, ich glaube, diese Geschichte mit dem Wortbildungselement kritisch, die ist ja schon aufgekommen im rechtspopulistischen Spektrum. Dass man also nicht sagt, wir sind schulenfreundlich, sondern wir sind schulenkritisch. Oder es gibt Asylkritiker. Oder Zuwanderungskritisch, statt eben ablehnend oder feindlich. Und das sind aber Wörter, das habe ich ja nun gerade auch versucht zu recherchieren. Man kann das leicht herausfinden, das sind inzwischen Wörter, die man in neutral geschriebenen Texten in Zeitungen liest.
Aber ist es nicht auch deshalb ein Problem, weil eine Demokratie muss ja tatsächlich auch aushalten, dass es Leute gibt, die Zuwanderung kritisch sehen. Also jetzt nicht in dem rechtspopulistischen Sinne, sondern die sagen, wir müssen vielleicht mal drüber reden, wie viel lassen wir wann rein.
Also da ist ja gemeint, wir lehnen es ab.
Genau, aber die Frage geht dann sozusagen, also das müsste man ja eigentlich aushalten können. Und ist das sozusagen nicht nur ein Trick, dass man das verkleidet, dass man sagt, okay, zuwanderungskritisch meint damit aber eigentlich ausländerfeindlich, sondern dass man auch sozusagen den Leuten, die tatsächlich einfach Kritik üben wollen, den Raum nimmt. Also die können ja jetzt nirgendswo mehr vorkommen. Also wenn es kritisch sozusagen belegt ist, dass die ganz weit außen und dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite nur noch dafür.
Genau, also es gibt tatsächlich, also wenn jemand sagt, naja, das Asylverfahren ist irgendwie nicht gut und praktisch das kritisiert, für den gibt es dann keinen Platz mehr, weil der ja nun kein Asylkritiker in diesem Sinn ist.
Das führt dann sozusagen aber auch zu einer weiteren Aufrüstung der Sprache, oder? Also hat das nicht zur Folge, dass alles immer weiter extremisiert wird, weil es dann genau nur noch diese Extreme gibt?
Ja, also das stimmt. Also in diesem Fall würde ich nicht so sehr von einer Aufrüstung sprechen, weil ja das ist ganz schwierig, weil ja kritisch...
Verschärfung der Diskussion vielleicht.
Ja, möglicherweise, genau, also so eine Konfrontation. Also es gibt nichts mehr im Übergang, es gibt dann im Grunde nur noch dafür und dagegen. Genau, ja. Wobei dieser Übergang ja immer problematisch ist. Also das ist ja möglicherweise auch gerade das Einfallstor dann, dass Leute, die sagen, naja, irgendwie funktioniert da was nicht richtig, dann plötzlich mehr und mehr dazu kommen, zu sagen, also eigentlich lehnen wir Asyl direkt ab.
Aber auch, weil sie nicht anders können, oder? Also ich stelle mir das zuvor, wenn du das so sagst.
Stimmt, stimmt, ja, weil es keine, es gibt halt dann nur noch die Abnehmung. Es gibt keinen Mittelraum.
Genau, also wenn man das kritisiert, dann sagen die Asylkritischen im Sinne von Populisten, ha ha, einer von uns.
Genau.
Und die sozusagen, die dagegen sagen, ha ha, einer von denen. Und dann kann man quasi gar nicht mehr reden. Und das aber Gewinn tut doch da sozusagen wiederum nur der Populismus.
Genau, da gewinnt der Populismus. Das ist ja dessen Strategie auch. Er möchte ja gewinnen. Und da macht er halt diese beiden Strategien auf der einen Seite aufzurüsten und zu provozieren. Also punktuell wird provoziert, indem man halt so ein Nazi-Wort verwendet. Und auf der anderen Seite wird eben versucht, Leute dann zu vereinnahmen, indem eben gerade dieses Mittelfeld wegfällt.
Was ich im letzten Jahr auch immer wieder gelesen habe, ist das unsagbare Sagbar-Machen als Strategie. Also man geht einmal ganz weit raus und sagt was ganz schlimm Ausländerfeindliches oder schwulenfeindliches und nimmt es dann zurück und sagt, das war jetzt auch Kreise, da bin ich auch mit der Maus ausgerutscht.
Genau, das ist im Haus gerutscht.
Genau, aber dann ist es einmal gesagt worden. Und weil man da so weit extrem draußen war und einen Schritt zurückgeht, ist aber dahinter sozusagen etwas, was nicht ganz so extrem ist, aber auf einmal sagbar ist, weil es nicht so schlimm ist, wie das, was man gerade verbrochen hat.
Genau, also das ist, ja, damit wird eben das, was dann gesagt wird, plötzlich wieder ganz normal. Also diese punktuellen Provokationen, ich glaube, das ist wirklich eine klare Strategie. Das sieht man bei all diesen Vertretern. Ich bin ja ein bisschen kritisiert worden für die Verwendung von Google Twents, aber das sollte ja nur eine gewisse Sache illustrieren. Und ich sehe die Problematik von Google Twents, aber was man eben sehr schön zeigen kann bei Google Twents, egal, ob das nun eine genaue Analyse ist, ist halt immer dieser Spike bei der Provokation. Also Frauke Petri sagt, völkisch muss wiederverwendbar sein. Das ist ein normales Adjektiv. Und dann geht das einmal so hoch, dann ist es auch wieder weg. Dann sieht man halt, dass es möglicherweise nicht ganz weg ist. Da ist es dann zu ungenau. Da müsste man jetzt mit der Presse-Datenbank das nachzählen. Aber es zeigt sich eben, dass es einmal diesen Spike gibt, dass es also eine punktuelle Provokation ist.
Jetzt ist ja was man... Also mangelndes eines besseren Begriffes, sage ich mal Gegenseite, ist ein Effekt, den ich meine, häufig zu beobachten, dass man quasi das Gegenteil von Populismus macht, sondern immer ganz genau sein will. Also ganz genau ausdefiniert, ganz perfekt, ganz unangreifbar letztendlich auch. Und darüber, was jetzt die wirklich echte, richtige Definition von Demokratie gibt, dass man quasi das irgendwie aus den Augen verliert. Ist das nur Einbildung oder ist das tatsächlich zu beobachten? Also gibt es einen Gegenwort zu Populismus? Superperfektionistisch?
Naja, das wäre nun wirklich superperfektionistisch, stimmt. Naja, aber das Gegenteil ist ja eigentlich Politik. Also wenn man nicht populistisch ist, dann...
Inwiefern?
Na ja, Politik ist ja natürlich was Kompliziertes. Wo halt eben Dinge ausdiskutiert werden müssen und eben auch geguckt werden muss, wie ist denn da noch mal eine Minderheit und all diese Dinge, die gehören ja leider zu. Von daher denke ich, seriöse Politik ist an sich nicht populistisch. Der ganze Rest ist Politik. Und das, was Populisten tun, ist halt Show.
Die ja aber, so zumindest die Bevölkerung sagen, sehr erfolgreich ist.
Ja, die ist erfolgreich, stimmt man ja.
Wenn man sich den rechtspopulistischen Ruck der ganzen Welt anguckt, dann verfängt das ja irgendwie. Wir brauchen, würde ich jetzt mal ganz populistisch behaupten, Gegenstrategien. Aber die Frage ist, wie die können ja aussehen.
Ja, das ist jetzt die große Frage. Da habe ich jetzt noch nicht so die perfekten Antworten.
Warum nicht? Es ist doch nächstes Jahr schon Wahl.
Ja, nächstes Jahr ist schon Wahl. Also, ich will jetzt nicht so defetistisch sein, aber ich habe fast das Gefühl, dass für die nächste Wahl gar nicht mehr so viel zu retten ist. Aber möglicherweise, wenn man sich Gedanken macht, ist vielleicht dann für danach noch was zu retten.
Also, wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, was die Wahl ist nicht mehr zu retten hat für danach, dann haben wir also auch Trump quasi als Entsprichtigung. Also, das ist ein bisschen bitter.
Das ist ein bisschen bitter, ja.
Aber warum meinst du, dass da nichts mehr zu retten ist? Also, hat das sozusagen so einen langen Vorlauf? Ist du Lawinenähnlich, dass man es jetzt nicht mehr aufhalten kann?
Also, ich stütze da meine Meinung so ein bisschen auf die Umfragen, wie sie jetzt sind. Und da sehe ich Schwermöglichkeiten, da eine große Wende jetzt noch einzuleuten, dass sich Leute anders entscheiden. Also, man sieht ja, dass Rechtspopulisten gerade sehr hoch im Kurs sind. Und Aufklärung zu machen, ist halt immer ein langwieriges Geschäft. Und ich meine, das wäre ja dann auch die Strategie, dass man Leuten versucht, eben die Probleme aufzuzeigen und es begreiflich zu machen. Aber bis das dann verfängt, das geht halt nicht so schnell. Von daher habe ich das Gefühl, dass jetzt also...
Aber kannst du was wie populistische Aufklärung geben?
Eben nicht. Populismus ist genau das Gegenteil von Aufklärung. Also vielleicht ist Aufklärung der Gegenbegriff zu Populismus.
Ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, weil was Aufklärung nicht leisten kann, ist bei jemanden verfangen, der sich nicht dafür interessiert. Populismus hängt ja schön nach, das kann man sich einfach anziehen. Deswegen finde ich auch, es wird ja immer gesagt, man muss Gegenrede machen und wenn jemand so was populistisch anhängt, dann muss man halt sagen, nee, das stimmt alles gar nicht. Aber was man dann häufig erlebt, ist ja dann auch so ein, nee, glaube ich dir nicht. Man ist in diesem eigenen oder angenommenen Realität nicht gefangen. Man ist da halt drin und nimmt dann auch gar nichts anderes mehr an.
Ja, aber es gibt so ein paar Dinge, die sich vielleicht ändern können, aber die sich auch nicht so kurzfristig ändern. Ich finde zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt ins Internet schaust und willst dich über irgendwas informieren, also bei mir war es ja so, für meine Recherchen habe ich ja eben so Texte gesucht, wo sich Leute im populistischen Bereich äußern. Und ich hatte dann auch noch so den Wunsch, dass ich jetzt nicht eine Plattform biete für die Vorredner, sondern dass man mal so ein bisschen guckt, was kommt an bei Leuten, die sich irgendwo äußern auf Demos oder so. Und das sind ja alles, da gibt es dann diese ganzen Interviews von ARD und ZDF, da gibt es wirklich eine Menge, nur ARD und ZDF haben das größtenteils nicht publiziert. Das heißt, ich musste jetzt gucken, wo finde ich solche Videos, die ich schon mal gesehen hatte, von denen ich wusste, dass es sie gibt. Also im Oktober 2015 war da ja mal so eine Geschichte, wo es auch so Diskussionen gab.
Wo die quasi die ungeschnittenen, das Rohmaterial, was auf so einer Demo angefallen ist.
Ja, gesucht und gesucht und gesucht. Und ich bin nicht richtig fündig geworden. Und dann hat eben mein Mitstreiter Kai Wiermann mir mal ein paar Links geschickt, wo die dann waren. Und das waren zum Teil eben genau die Seiten, auf die ich nicht gucken wollte. Und das zeigt doch so ein bisschen das Problem. Also ich glaube, es wäre gut, wenn halt solche Sachen nicht depublisiert werden, sondern eben einfach auch zur Verfügung stehen. Und da habe ich schon viel gewonnen. Ich glaube, mit einem Teil des Erfolgs liegt eben daran, dass in sozialen Netzwerken, und dazu gehört natürlich auch YouTube, eben aufgrund der Strategie, dass Sachen depubliziert werden, dass eben Informationen an einer bestimmten Stelle fehlen, eben Rechtspopulisten auch so eine Art Deutungshoheit haben, weil deren Material eben da ist.
Okay, eine andere Sache, die ich noch fragen wollte ist, oder einen anderen Vorschlag, den man hört, ist sozusagen, vielleicht müssen wir wieder härter in die Diskussion gehen. Und zwar hat, ich habe jetzt leider den Namen vergessen, das ist ein österreichischer Philosophie-Professor Liesmann heißt der, glaube ich. Ja, habe ich hier, also... Der hat so etwas in der Richtung gesagt, also im Prinzip haben wir uns in der öffentlichen Auseinandersetzung, sozusagen jetzt sehr lange so ein zurückhaltendes Ding angewöhnt. Also man wirklich jede Meinung wird beachtet, wirklich jede Meinung bekommt Raum und das ist total gut für Minderheitenschutz, aber verhindert auch, also seine These, wie ich sie verstanden habe, dass man im Zweifel mal auf den Tisch haut und sagt, das ist Quatsch, sowas darf nicht sein. Und ich finde das einerseits zu faszinierenden Gedanken, dass man sozusagen über die Sanfheit, mit der man miteinander umgeht, die ja eigentlich eine gute Sache ist, so was Tür und Tor offnet, dass man sagt, okay, das Problem ist, man ist dann nicht mehr militant genug, wenn es darauf ankommt. Andererseits finde ich es auch schwierig, das so zu sagen, weil ich habe das manchmal so sagen, als jetzt Trump gewählt wurde und die AfD irgendwo einzogelassen hat, da hatte ich so manchmal, also in mir so, nicht dass ich das will, aber ich hatte sozusagen als Emotion so ein ganz antidemokratisches Gefühl, wo ich so dachte, vielleicht sollen die einfach nicht wählen. Die Leute so. Das geht natürlich, das geht natürlich gar nicht.
Aber Informationsunterdrückung oder zu sagen, das wollen wir jetzt nicht, sondern nur noch diese Information, nicht alle können zu Wort kommen, ist eine schlechte Strategie. Denn man hört das ja auch immer, das hatte ich ja auch, wie wird Wahrheit definiert bei den Rechtspopulisten? Wahrheit wird dadurch definiert, dass irgendein, also wahr ist, was nicht gesagt werden darf. Also es wird so, also das Wahre wird definiert aus dem, was vermeintlich unterdrückt wird. Wenn jetzt sich aber noch wiederum bestätigt, dass bestimmte Sachen nicht kommen, dann verstärkt sich das natürlich noch.
Also quasi die Wahrheit ist dann immer das Ungesagte, das Nibollöse, was man auch gar nicht, achso, man muss gar nicht sagen, was man als wahr hält, weil sozusagen man ja immer darauf verweisen kann, man dürfe es nicht sagen.
Genau.
Das ist natürlich noch schöner als extrem zu machen. Aber trotzdem, die, also glaubst du, dass man, das ist auch eine Frage, die man ja auch taucht, glaubst du, dass man alle erreichen kann? Also wenn man jetzt dieses Konzept der Gegenrede und Information und nicht die Publizierung von, wenn man wirklich alle erreicht, dann gibt es vielleicht doch einen Punkt, wo man sagt, okay, es wird einfach nie klappen, dass wir alle Leute mitnehmen. Also ist das sozusagen...
Alle Leute wird man nie mitnehmen, man muss halt genügend Leute mitnehmen und...
Aber wo zieht man die Grenze, das ist ja die spannende Frage, wo ziehe ich jetzt also ganz konkret als Individuum die Grenze und sage, also hier lohnt es noch zu diskutieren und das ist einfach also verloren und dann will ich nicht nur nicht mit dem reden, sondern dann will ich auch klar eine Grenze ziehen und sagen, du bist so weit außerhalb, dann ist es mir egal, ob du jetzt sagst, siehste, du bist ein Meinungsunterdrücker.
Naja, ja, das ist wirklich schwer zu entscheiden, also gerade weil du ja Trump anspaarst, also das ist... Also mit Trump muss man natürlich sich jetzt auseinandersetzen und das wäre schon so jemand, wo ich auch sagen würde, meine Güte, also das ist sehr, sehr schwierig. Also da so eine Grenze zu ziehen, also man muss dann wahrscheinlich pragmatisch entscheiden in der Situation, wenn man irgendwo ist und mit jemandem diskutiert, muss man sich überlegen, tatsächlich in der Situation kriege ich da nun noch irgendwie Argumente, einen argumentativen Austausch hin. Das heißt ja nicht, dass dann meine Argumente unbedingt immer gleich alle überzeugen, aber geht es noch zu argumentieren oder ist es soweit, dass ja eine Kommunikation schon nicht mehr möglich ist, weil eben der Verständnis über die grundlegenden Griffe sehr unterschiedlich ist.
Aber ist das auch etwas, was wir vielleicht für uns selber auch mitnehmen müssen, im Sinne von man soll in Diskussion gehen, aber man kann halt nicht immer erwarten, dass man komplett überzeugt?
Ja, das sowieso. Also man kann nicht immer erwarten, komplett zu überzeugen, aber darum geht es ja gar nicht. Also auch wenn man schon so ein bisschen Argumente austauscht, kann das ja für beide Seiten vorteilhaft sein. Aber wie gesagt, wenn sich zeigt, dass es eben schon an sich die Kommunikation nicht geht, dann finde ich, sollte man vielleicht auch seine Zeit sinnvoller nutzen. Also es ist halt wirklich schwierig, man muss das in einem jeweiligen Fall entscheiden. Da kommen ja auch noch andere Dinge dazu. Ist der Gesprächspartner einem doch irgendwie sympathisch oder unsympathisch oder so? Also wie gesagt, man muss dann wirklich pragmatisch vorgehen.
Na gut, schauen wir mal, wie das wird. Worüber wirst du denn nächstes Jahr an dieser Stelle reden? Vermutet von hier aus?
Das weiß ich noch nicht. Wir müssen mal sehen, was im nächsten Jahr noch alles passiert. Also da könnten dann auch ganz neue Dinge wieder auf uns zurollen. Das mit der Sprache der Propelisten war ja auch in gewisser Weise neu. Es geht zwar um Sprache, aber es geht eigentlich gar nicht so sehr um die Sprache der Politiker selbst, sondern um die Sprache eines Milieus, was ja schon mal anders ist. Und da kann im nächsten Jahr sicherlich noch ganz was anderes passieren. Wir wissen, also gerade im Moment wissen wir gar nicht, was sich weiterentwickelt. Was passiert mit Trump und was macht er und so. Und von daher können da ganz neue Dinge auf uns zukommen und dann natürlich auch wieder in Deutschland. Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt so hört, was wieder alles für neue Überwachungsdinge ganz selbstverständlich in die Diskussion geworfen werden, dann wird sich einiges aufdun. Wenn du jetzt gerade hörst in Berlin will jetzt der Regierende Bürgermeister doch wieder mehr Videoüberwachung, obwohl eigentlich alles schon ausdiskutiert ist und sie haben einen Koalitionsvertrag, ja und jetzt trotzdem wieder sowas. Also da kommen sicherlich auch wieder Dinge auf uns zu, die dann vielleicht auch sprachlich interessant sind. Denn gerade in solchen Situationen geht es ja wieder darum, irgendwas zu verkaufen, was eigentlich unverkäuflich ist.
Aber ganz, ganz, ganz ehrlich, ich würde mich nächstes Jahr an dieser Stelle lieber wieder über sozusagen Überwachungsneussprüche unterhalten als über, wie man sozusagen in einem Meer von Rechtspopulismus überlegt. Ich finde, das ist ein Zeichen der Zeit sozusagen, dass man sagt, okay, das wäre mir eigentlich lieber, also das ist eine Pest und Cholera. Na gut, Martin Haase war das über Neusprechte Rechtspopulisten hier am Chaosradio 230.
Vielen Dank.
So, das war Limes mit Wonderland vom Chillhop Winter Soundtrack. Links gibt's dann nachher in den Show notes, jetzt beim Chaosradio 230. Und da gibt es auch heute wieder, wie fast bei jedem Chaosradio, ungefähr Nerd News präsentiert werden die heute von Holgi. Herzlich willkommen. Willkommen.
Hallo ist das meistgenutzte deutsche Passwort. Das Hasso-Platner-Institut gab in der letzten Woche eine Liste der zehn meistverwendeten Passwörter auf Internetseiten mit DE-Domains heraus. Das Passwort Hallo steht dabei an erster Stelle abgeschlagen auf Platz 10 folgt Ficken. Die Passwörter stammen aus insgesamt 31 Datenleaks, die frei abrufbar seien. Es gibt keinen hundertprozentigen Schutz vor Identitätsdiebstahl, so HPI-Direktor und Mitautor der Studie Professor Christoph Meinl. Aber, wer sein Passwort auf dieser Liste entdeckt, sollte es schnellstmöglich ändern. Breitband-Flatrate für alle in Kanada. Die kanadische Telekom-Regulierungsbehörde CRTC hat Breitband-Internet mit mindestens 50 Megabit pro Sekunde im Download und 10 Megabit pro Sekunde im Upload bei unlimitiertem Datenvolumen zum Basisdienst erklärt. Nach der Definition des Basisdienstes sollen die Datenraten an jedem Anschluss tatsächlich erreicht werden und nicht nur ein theoretisches Maximum sein. In Zitat 10 bis 15 Jahren sollen alle Kanadier einen solchen Internetanschluss nutzen können. In Deutschland gibt es bislang zwar Diskussionen, aber keine ernsthaften Bestrebungen von Regierungs- oder Regulierungsseite, den Begriff Universaldienst auf Breitband-Internet auszuweiten. Immerhin, das aktuelle Telekommunikationsgesetz gewährleistet jedem Bürger einen Telefax-Anschluss. Nach 16 Jahren verlässt Kai Diekmann den Axel-Springer-Verlag. Das teilte der Verlag am Vormittag in einer Pressemitteilung mit. Diekmann könne auf eine einzigartige Karriere bei Axel Springer zurückblicken, so Matthias Döpfner, Vorstandsvorsitzender bei Springer. Wir sind traurig über sein Ausscheiden. Diekmann wechselt im Frühjahr ins Kanzleramt und ersetzt den bisherigen Chef des Bundespresse- und Informationsamts der Bundesregierung, Steffen Seibert, erfuhr die Redaktion aus gewöhnlich gut informierten Kreisen. Pläne für Abwehrzentrum gegen Fake News Das Bundesinnenministerium plädiert dafür, möglichst schnell ein sogenanntes Abwehrzentrum gegen Desinformationen einzurichten. Das berichtet der Spiegel unter Berufung auf ein internes Papier. Darin fordern die Beamten schnelles Handeln angesichts der anstehenden Bundestagswahl und der Erfahrungen bei der amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahl. Da der Schwerpunkt bei der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit liegt, sollte die Federführung für dieses zu schaffende Bündelungseinheit, Verzeihung für die seezuschaffende Bündelungseinheit, beim Bundespresseamt angesiedelt werden, so das Papier. Damit würde das Abwehrzentrum der Behörde des im Frühjahr ausscheidenden Pressesprechers Steffen Seibert zugeschlagen.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt. Heißt das sozusagen, dass Kai Diekmann in Zukunft dafür zuständig sein wird, Fake-News aufzuhalten?
Alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich bin gerade aufgestanden und es ist das erste Mal, dass ich überhaupt einen zusammenhangenden Satz aus diesem Zellhaufen gepresst habe.
Ich bin der Klein mit den Neuen News, vielen Dank!
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio 230.
Kann ich einen Kaffee?
Den Magazin für nachhaltige Berichterstattung und einen Kaffee für Holger Klein bitte. Vielen Dank für die Nerd-News.
Ich muss jetzt gehen, oder?
Hast du sehr gut gemacht, dafür, dass du so ein Alter, äh, so ein...
Dafür, dass es gestern so spät war. Ich hab das Mikrofon kaputt gemacht.
Auch das noch. Jetzt widmen wir uns einem Thema, das also nicht die anderen beiden Themen, die hatten sie ja über Jahre schon weggetragen. Das, was wir jetzt machen, ist also zumindest im Rahmen dieser Sendung neu, ähm, weil es ist erst seit letztem Jahr so richtig groß, ähm, und zwar geht's um Dieselgate. Und jetzt kommt auch der Teil, wo das Chaosradio seinen Namen zurechtlegt. Ich weiß nämlich deinen Namen nicht so richtig.
Daniel Lange.
Daniel Lange, herzlich willkommen. Du bist einer von den beiden Leuten, die auch im vergangenen Jahr schon zu Dieselgate, ähm, vorgetragen haben. Und das ist ganz spannend. Also Dieselgate, ganz kurze, geht's darum, dass in VW-Fahrzeugen Software so eingestellt war, dass die Abgaswerte, naja, sagen wir mal, beschönigt wurden.
Nicht nur eingestellt waren, sondern eingestellt sind, weil die Rückrufe da ja erst am 21.12. wirklich vollständig freigegeben worden sind vom Kraftfahrtbundesamt. Und da ist halt jetzt die Frage, was die Leute machen, weil das ist eine ganz interessante Diskrepanz. Das Kraftfahrtbundesamt sagt, das ist ein freiwilliger Rückruf, aber der ist verpflichtend. Die Leute sollen hingehen.
Freiwilliger Rückruf heißt?
Freiwilliger Rückruf heißt, VW ist nicht verpflichtet, diesen Rückruf zu machen, wie es zum Beispiel wären, wenn es ein sicherheitsrelevantes Thema wäre. Aber damit ist dieser Rückruf halt auch nicht für den Kunden verpflichtend. Das Kraftfahrtbundesamt und insbesondere die Briefe von VW sagen aber was anderes. Die sagen, es könnte ihnen die TÜV-Plakette verweigert werden und solche Dinge. Und das ist eben jetzt interessant zu sehen, was da passieren wird, weil die Leute, die klagen, bekommen halt das Fahrzeug gewandelt oder bekommen halt eine substanzielle Kompensationszahlung, zum Beispiel für ein Leasing-Rückgabe. Und die Leute, die das eben nicht machen, die bekommen halt so ein Plastikrohr eingesetzt in das Fahrzeug, was das Strömungsverhalten von der Luft verbessert und damit die Verbrennung besser berechenbar macht und damit es einfacher macht, die Verbrennung so zu optimieren, dass sie emissionsoptimal ist. Und VW sagt, dass sie während der Zeit, wo das eingebaut wird, auch adäquate Ersatzmobilität bekommen. Also man darf vermuten, dass sie irgendwie was Besseres als ein Fahrrad bekommen.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man so ein Auto hat, sollte man besser das nicht machen, sondern klagen?
Ja, genau. Also im Moment sieht es so aus, dass die VW hat einseitig bis 31.12. nächsten Jahres auf die Verjährung verzichtet und empfiehlt das auch ihren Händlern. Dein Vertragspartner ist ja der Händler. Das heißt, du musst sozusagen den Händler bitten, das Fahrzeug zum Beispiel zurückzunehmen, weil du sagst, die Verbrauchsangaben stimmen ja gar nicht und ich habe das Fahrzeug auch gekauft, weil es besonders umweltfreundlich ist und das ist es nicht und deswegen ist ein wesentlicher Grund für mich entfallen, dass ich das Fahrzeug überhaupt haben möchte. Außerdem habt ihr mich betrogen und deswegen will ich das auch nicht mehr oder sowas. Und der Händler soll jetzt nach VW auch diese Verjährung bis 31.12.2017 nicht geltend machen. Weil meistens ist es so, dass die Fahrzeuge ja älter als zwei Jahre sind und damit halt die gesetzliche Gewährleistung ausgelaufen ist. Empfehlungsgemäß würde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt bis Oktober, November nächsten Jahr aus die Füße stillhalten und gucken, was passiert, ob vielleicht VW doch noch auch in Europa mit einem vernünftigen Angebot rumkommt. Und wenn nicht, kann man sich einfach einer der Kanzleien, die das für Hunderte schon machen, anschließen, die erheben dann Klage, das kostet wirklich nur ein paar Euro, damit ist die Frist sozusagen gesichert. Und dann kann man halt mit den VW-Anwälten, die den Händler wiederum beraten und auch vertreten, reden. Und normalerweise kommt dann da ein schöner 5-stelliger Betrag raus.
Okay, und dann darf man aber sein Auto nicht reparieren lassen vorher?
Genau, das sollte man nicht tun, weil nach deutschem Recht ist es so, dass der Mangel dann ja geheilt wäre. Und außerdem ist es so, dass man so ein Stapel Papier vorgelegt bekommt und in dem es natürlich unter anderem auch versteckt, dass man dann eben sozusagen einverstanden ist mit dem, was da passiert und damit für einen selber sozusagen der Mangel ausgestanden ist. Der Mangel ist aber natürlich für viele Leute, glaube ich, gar nicht die Tatsache, dass das Auto eben hinten mehr NOX rausbläst, wenn man den Testzyklus auf der Straße fährt gegenüber dem Testzyklus auf der Rolle, weil beides machen die Menschen nicht. Sondern der Mangel ist halt, dass es einfach viel mehr hinten rausbläst, als es in der Zulassung hat und damit einfach dreckiger ist und zum Beispiel Feinstaub in den Städten erzeugt und Lungenkrankheiten und das andere ist halt, dass man eben viel Geld für ein Auto ausgegeben hat, was besonders sauber ist und das war halt eben Marketing und nicht technische Realität.
Jetzt habt ihr letztes Jahr einen Vortrag gehalten, den ich richtig erinnere. Habt ihr da sozusagen sehr eindrucksvoll gezeigt, dass das nicht sozusagen, da hat ein Ingenieur also ohne das Wissen von irgendjemand so ein Ding mal halt geändert und dann ist es halt so passiert, sondern dass das schon mehr oder weniger geplant sein muss mit Wissen des Managements und das sozusagen, das ist halt also wirklich. Genau. Genau. So dieses Jahr, ich hab leider selber nicht sehen können, aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es sozusagen, das ist gar nicht nur VW. Ihr habt jetzt mal losgezogen, habt mal geguckt, wo ist das sonst noch so.
Genau, also letztes Jahr war sozusagen die Behauptung von mir und der Grund, warum ich überhaupt das gemacht habe, ich habe mit VW ansonsten nichts zu tun, dass VW eben gesagt hat, das ist eine kleine Gruppe von Ingenieuren, die das gemacht haben, Rogue Group of Engineers war die englische Formulierung und das arme Management sei halt betrogen worden von denen und man möge doch möglichst viel Mitleid haben und als jemand, der selber viel mehr als ein Jahrzehnt in der Automobilienstrige gearbeitet hat, war mir sofort klar, das ist Bullshit. Der Ingenieur hat ja überhaupt kein Interesse zu betrügen, der möchte ein besseres Auto entwickeln und wenn der betrügt, dann liegt das daran, dass mir ihn das bessere Auto nicht entwickeln lässt. Und das habe ich eben dann 2015 gezeigt. 2016 hat sich dann relativ schnell, so im Januar, Februar, durch einen Leak von VW und dann so im April durch, sage ich mal, geänderte Sprache bei VW eingeräumt, dass das wohl doch mehr Leute waren, die da beteiligt sind. Es gibt nur mit 28 Ermittlungsverfahren, die bei der Staatsanwaltschaft anhängig sind, unter anderem eben auch gegen sehr seniore Manager. Es sind ja auch viele freigestellt worden, haben dann einen Aufhebungsvertrag unterschrieben. VW hat die natürlich nicht gefeuert, sondern hat ihnen noch viel Geld hinterher geschickt, damit sie freiwillig gehen. Ja, du bist vielleicht auch nicht korrupt genug, um in dem Beruf erfolgreich zu sein, weil nur wenn du das zuerst bist, kriegst du nachher die Kohle.
Okay, gut, dann ist es vielleicht doch gut so, wie es ist.
Genau, um auf den zweiten Teil der Frage einzugehen, VW ist immer schwer im Fokus und ich bin da mitschuldig. Ich habe bei dem Vortrag jetzt auch im Endeffekt nur VW gezeigt, habe aber ganz vorher eine Folie gezeigt, dass fast alle anderen auch bescheißen und nachher noch mal darauf hingewiesen, dass das wichtig ist, nur du hast halt nur eine halbe Stunde und so musst du halt priorisieren. Und VW bietet einfach so viel Notwendigkeit zur Klarstellung, dass es kaum möglich ist, genug über die anderen zu reden. Aber ja, die anderen bescheißen genauso. Also in Deutschland Opel ist erwischt worden von der Deutschen Umwelthilfe. Der Felix hat dann den tollen Auftrag bekommen, vom Kraftfahrtbundesamt doch mal zu verifizieren, dass das, wie das die gefixt haben, auch wirklich dieses Defeat Device, diese Betrugssoftware ausbaut, was eben zeigt, dass Kraftfahrtbundesamt nicht mal mehr Leute hat, die das selber können.
Puh, das vertrauenerweckt.
Ja, und das ist halt die Regulationsbehörde. Also Regulation funktioniert in Deutschland im Moment so, dass Unternehmen geht hin und misst sein Fahrzeug und gibt aber ganz wichtige Parameter, zum Beispiel die Einstellwiderstände für den Rollenprüfstand an. Das heißt, wenn du die ein bisschen verkehrt machst, hast du mal locker 10-20% weniger Emissionen und niemand überprüft die eigentlich. Mit diesen Infos gehen sie dann zum TÜV oder zu einer anderen Prüfeinrichtung, die zugelassen ist. Das sind im Prinzip die gleichen, wo ihr eure privaten Autos auch hinbringt und lassen dieses Fahrzeug dann sozusagen überprüfen. Und das ist ein iterativer Prozess, der funktioniert so lange, bis der TÜV sozusagen die Werte rausgekriegt hat, die gültig sind für die Zulassung. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwas verkehrt ist, das ist ja ein Vor-Serien-Fahrzeug, dann gehen die natürlich friedlich zu ihrem Kunden und sagen, hey, aber die Werte stimmen doch noch nicht. Und dann sagt dann eben der Hersteller, ach Mensch, das tut uns aber leid, da müssen wir wohl die falsche Software geliefert haben, da gucken wir nochmal und dann kommt eine Woche später eine neue Software mit, der geht's dann. Und das wird eben so lange gemacht, bis man dann zufrieden ist. Und die Werte gehen dann eben zum Kraftfahrtbundesamt und das Kraftfahrtbundesamt überprüft dann eben diese Zulassungsunterlagen und die Tests und so weiter und gibt dann eben sein Okay da drauf. Da findet aber eben abgesehen von der Dokumentenanalyse nicht wirklich irgendwie was statt. Und zumindest nichts, was ein Eindringtiefe hätte, dass man eben auch in der Lage wäre, Betrug zu entdecken.
Also vorwärts, ich möchte wirklich gerne gleich nochmal drüber reden, zu sagen, wer jetzt noch alles, aber da würde ich jetzt mal fragen, wie müsste denn so ein Prüfverfahren überhaupt aussehen, damit es den Namen verdient?
Also es gibt natürlich zwei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Möglichkeit ist, du machst das so wie die Amerikaner. Du hast Behörden, die wissen, was sie tun, die Spezialisten haben, die, das ist ein bisschen so eine amerikanische Sache, einfach auch stolz sind, für die Regierung zu arbeiten und deswegen also auch durchaus, wenn sie woanders höhere Gehälter bekommen können, relativ freiwillig von der Automobilindustrie zur Behörde wechseln, damit Kompetenz mitbringen und umgekehrt auch wieder natürlich eine Chance haben, von der Behörde wieder in die Automobilindustrie zu wechseln. Das ist natürlich ein Thema, was an sich auch problematisch ist, genau wie bei Politikern. Aber ich meine, du musst natürlich auch in deinen einzelnen Menschen denken, du darfst ihm jetzt nicht den Karriereweg zumachen, wenn er einmal auf BAT 12a sitzt, im Kraftfahrtbundesamt und da darf er nie mehr wieder irgendwie echtes Geld verdienen. Also da muss man auch gucken, wie man das hinkriegt. Aus meiner persönlichen Sicht, solange das transparent ist, ist das immer gut. Also wenn klar ist, der kommt von da, der geht nach da und es ist auch klar, wie das passiert ist und der ist vielleicht nicht gerade bei der Automobilindustrie dann direkt für Regulation zuständig, sondern vielleicht für was anderes. Also ich denke, das kann man schon fair machen. Das ist die eine Methode. Du hast Leute, die das können. Die andere Methode ist…
Also nur um das kann ich gerade sagen, das ist in Deutschland nicht so.
Das ist in Deutschland nicht so gut. Die stützen sich hundert Prozent auf die Prüforganisationen ab und die haben es entweder nicht gewusst oder nicht wissen wollen, was da über ein Jahrzehnt lang passiert ist.
Die leben auch vom Geld der Automobilindustrie.
Das ist das Problem. Sie sind halt auch ihre Kunden. Aber sie haben eben auch einen öffentlichen Auftrag, zum Beispiel halt von dem Kraftfahrtbundesamt oder auch bei Stichprobenüberprüfungen vom Verkehrsministerium. Also die Frage ist, ist es bis heute unklar? Es ermittelt da soweit, ich weiß auch keiner, ob die unfähig sind oder ob die unwillig waren. Also eins von beiden muss ja sein, also ich meine, wenn du halt dutzende Fahrzeuge zulässt und Millionen Fahrzeuge auf der Straße überprüfst und dann nicht feststellst, dass Autos irgendwie nur ein Drittel von dem AirBlue, also diesem Beimischungszeug, was... Also wenn du ein ganz modernes Fahrzeug hast, also so Euro5-aufwärts, ein Dieselfahrzeug, dann wird dem, damit es bessere Abgaswerte erzeugt, vor allem NOX, eine Flüssigkeit zugemischt, eine wässrige Harnstofflösung, das ist als Markenname AdBlue und die Dinger haben Tank. Und eines der großen Probleme der Hersteller ist und war, dass einfach die Tanks zu klein sind. Weil, als man festgestellt hat, dass man das braucht, hat man halt das Reserve Rad rausgeschmissen. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum viele Autos heute halt eben so eine Flüssigkeit haben und so eine Luftpumpe, die dir sowieso nie hilft, weil die Perforation vom Reifen so ist, dass du das damit eh nicht dicht kriegst, sonst ist die Felge nachher komplett versaut. Also, eine ganz blöde Idee. Aber es braucht halt viel weniger Bauraum und diesen Bauraum kann man nun halt nutzen, um zum Beispiel so einen Tank für dieses AdBlue einzubauen oder jetzt in Zukunft eben, um ein E-Auto aus deinem Auto zu machen, in dem halt ein kleiner Lithium-Ionen-Akku verbaut wird, der eben so als Booster das Anfahren unterstützt und eben dann aus dem Fahrzeugen Hybrid macht.
Ich soll mal sagen, dieser Tank ist sozusagen sehr klein gewesen und damit der Autobesitzer, dem nicht zumutet, dass er den so oft nachfüllen muss, hat man die Werte sozusagen so runter geschraubt, dass man nicht so oft...
Exakt, genau. Also, in Amerika war es eine Zeit lang so, dass man 100 Meilen schaffen musste zwischen den Inspektionsintervallen. Also, die Amerikaner wollten, dass die Leute halt mit dem Auto eben auch fahren konnten und nicht ständig beim Händler sein müssen. Deswegen hatten die diese 10.000 Meilen-Regelung gemacht. Das konnte man eben mit einem 10 oder 12 Liter Elblut-Tank auf gar keinen Fall schaffen. Du brauchst so ungefähr 1, 6 Liter auf 1.000 Kilometer. Und in Europa war es eben auch so ein Convenienz-Thema. Ich meine es klar, wenn du vom Euro-4-Diesel kommst und so ein Diesel ist toll, einmal tankt, 1.000 Kilometer fahren, braucht wenig Sprit, schönes Auto und du gehst dann eben Richtung Euro-5 und Euro-6 und dann hast du eben die Situation, du musst jetzt noch irgendeine Flüssigkeit nachfüllen, die ist auch ein bisschen schwierig in der Handhabung. Da hat man sich dann so Spezialflaschen überlegt, die man so auf den Tank drücken muss und auf den Tank öffnet dann sozusagen die Flasche, weil das Zeug ist eben auch, sag ich mal, nicht so angenehm in der Handhabung, macht fiese Flecken und so. Also in Folge dessen ist das ein Convenienz-Thema. Die Automobilindustrie wollte das eigentlich vom Kunden verstecken, dass man das jetzt braucht, um umweltfreundlichere Autos zu haben. Das ist natürlich ein typischer Marketing-Fail eigentlich. Die Leute, die diese Autos gekauft haben, haben sie vielleicht häufig nicht nur aus Convenienzgründen gekauft, sondern auch, weil sie eben besonders umweltfreundlich Autos haben. Ich meine, die Leute fahren halt auch Fahrrad, weil das anstrengend ist und weil das sie ein bisschen trainiert und weil sie jeden Tag erinnert werden, dass sie halt weniger Dreck verursachen, als wenn sie Auto fahren. Also denke ich, hätte man das durchaus auch anders machen können und sagen können, hier, also das ist eben auch dein Beitrag zum Umweltbewusst-der-und-fahren, aber hat man halt nicht gemacht und dann hast du halt das Problem, die Tanks sind zu klein und dann, was machst du jetzt? Also eigentlich will man nur beim Händler nachfüllen, man will dem Händler auch den Umsatz halt sichern, dass der nicht einfach an der Tankstelle das AdBlue kauft, das ist dann ganz billig. Richtig, ja, man guckst dir an, also du zahlst halt im Supermarkt für ein Öl, für ein durchschnittliches Auto, vielleicht irgendwie acht Liter, wenn du gut, acht Euro für ein Liter, wenn du gut einkaufst, an der Tankstelle zahlst du 15 Euro, bei deinem Autohändler zahlst du 30 Euro. Das ist gleiche Öl. Und beim AdBlue ist das halt genauso, da kannst du einen 10 Liter Kanister für 15 Euro bei Amazon kaufen, du kannst aber auch für 150 Euro beim Händler deines Vertrauens kaufen. Das ist natürlich viel besser. Das ist viel besseres AdBlue, das ist handgeliebt. Die Problematik ist halt, dass die Autohersteller natürlich wissen, dass ihre Händler in Zukunft nicht mehr so super viel Umsatz haben werden. Weil ein Elektroauto besteht aus viel weniger Komponenten als ein Verbrenner, ist viel wartungsfreundlicher. Denk mal allein an das Thema Bremsen. Heute rubbelst du bei 200 kmh mit Bremsplatten auf einer Metallscheibe rum. Das wird irgendwie mörderheiß. Das gibt viel Abrieb und halt so nach, weißt nicht, 30 bis 60.000 Kilometer je nach Auto musst du die Dinge halt tauschen. Das ist Umsatz, das ist gutes Geld. Beim Elektroauto ist es so, das bremst erst mal in der Rekuperation. Das heißt, das schaltet seinen Motor vom Antrieb auf den Generator. Und bremst dadurch erst mal saustark. Das heißt, du brauchst eigentlich überhaupt mal keine mechanische Bremse, wenn du geschickt fährst. Wenn du nicht ganz so geschickt fährst, brauchst du die mechanische Bremse die letzten 10 Meter vor der Ampel, damit du genau an der richtigen Stelle anhälst. Das ist ein Lifetime-Produkt geworden. Das heißt, du kannst eigentlich kleinere Bremsen einbauen, die trotzdem Lifetime halten, damit entfällt ein Umsatz. Öl gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Wir biegen jetzt ein bisschen ab, aber ich möchte die Frage kurz stellen, hast du schon einen Verdacht, was man in Elektroautos einbauen wird? Was dann sozusagen so, ah schade, aber das muss man jetzt wirklich alle 5000 km auswechseln?
Es gibt ja verschiedene Ansätze. Es gibt Leute, die die Akkus zum Beispiel nur vermieten, was natürlich dann so ein bisschen eine Verschiebung ist. Du gehst zwar vielleicht nicht unbedingt zu dem Händler, aber du hast jetzt trotzdem auf einmal monatliche Zahlungen. Was man auch gerne macht, ist diese Telematik-Lösung, also dass man ein Audi Connect oder ein BMW Connected Drive oder so etwas braucht, das ist dann zwei Jahre kostenlos. Nach zwei Jahren muss man eben eine jährliche Gebühr bezahlen. Es gibt natürlich jede Menge Möglichkeiten, Zusatzgebühren zu bezahlen. Beispiel, beim Elektroauto ist es ziemlich wichtig, dass du eine aktuelle Navi-Karte hast, weil du hast ein Auto, das fährt nur 100 Kilometer, deswegen musst du wissen, wo eine Tank-Säule ist. Die Tank-Säulen sind natürlich nicht ordentlich standardisiert. Das heißt, du brauchst diese Aussagen auch wirklich von deinem Autohersteller, weil sonst stehst du halt vor so einer Tapsäule. Die wäre auch da, die nimmt aber erstens deine Kreditkarte nicht, weil sie irgendein anderes proprietäres System hat. Und zweitens, nachdem du das Problem gelöst hast, weil ein netter Mensch, der auch da war, seinem Elektromobilitätskollegen geholfen hat, stellst du fest, Stecker geht nicht. Falsches System. Das heißt, du brauchst diese Daten, das kann man toll vermieten.
Aber im Grunde genommen wird es tatsächlich nicht mehr so sein, dass es irgendwie so Verbrauchsteil im Auto gibt, sondern dass es eher dieses Auto-Asset-Service ist.
Also geplante Obsolenz ist natürlich auch in der Automobilindustrie ein Riesenthema. Es lässt sich sicherlich eine Methode finden und ich fürchte, dass natürlich auch darüber nachgedacht wird, innerhalb der Automobilhersteller, wie man seinem Händler denn die Umsätze sichern kann. Das geht dann natürlich wieder Richtung kriminelle Aktivität, aber es ist ja, wie wir gerade sehen, nicht etwas, was so von der Hand zu weisen ist, dass die Automobilindustrie das tun würde.
Okay, warte, dann sprechen wir darüber nächstes Jahr. Und jetzt zurück zum eigentlichen Thema, nämlich wer hat denn noch alles mit dem Abgas sozusagen, wer hat noch alles ein Dieselgate auf Kleber verdient?
Also Stand heute sind eigentlich alle anderen Automobilhersteller betroffen, außer BMW. Ja, das ist ganz witzig. Ich meine, ich komme ja von BMW, muss man sagen.
Das ist verdächtig.
Ja, ich bin aber vor drei Jahren raus und hab meine eigene Firma gegründet, also das macht mich vielleicht etwas unabhängiger. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass also die Franzosen, die Italiener, also Fiat, da gibt es von der Deutschen Umwelthilfe Nachweise für, wo die das ungefähr 17 bis 20-fache der erlaubten Emissionen raushauen. Die haben ganz normale Defeat Devices, die haben auch teilweise bei Bosch eingekauft. Die gibt es dann vielleicht, weiß nicht, die Möglichkeit, dass man eben Erfahrungen von VW sozusagen weitergibt, dass man schon besseres Defeat Device bekommt. Und bei Fiat ist es halt so, die haben einen Timer zum Beispiel drin. Also die haben gar nicht so komplex beschissen. VW hat das ja gemacht, dass sie so die Kurven erkennen, die die Leute eben auf dem Prüfstand fahren und sobald du die verletzt, wird das Auto halt schmutzig. Fiat hat nicht so viel Ingenieurleistung reingesteckt, die haben einfach einen Timer gemacht. Die schalten halt nach irgendwie 300 Sekunden die Abgasregelung komplett ab und bis dahin ist der Test hoffentlich gelaufen. Also Opel hat auch eine schöne Kiste zum Beispiel, die schalten diese Abgasregelung im Wesentlichen komplett aus, nachdem was Felix analysiert hat und nachdem was so kolportiert wird vom Kraftfahrtbundesamt und da er ja den Fix verifiziert hat, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das auch so stimmt. Wenn du über 145 fährst, schalten das komplett aus und du musst wieder unter 135, damit es überhaupt einschalten und um in den richtig sauberen Modus zurückzukommen, musst du bei niedriger Geschwindigkeit auf Engine Idle gehen, das heißt also kein Gas geben. Das passiert dir natürlich, wenn du auf der Autobahn fährst, nie, das heißt, du fährst irgendwann mal aus deiner Stadt raus auf die Landstraße, dann geht das Ding halt in schlechten Modus und auf der Autobahn falls du 145 erreichst sowieso und dann bis du ankommst, ist das Auto dreckig und dann machst du es aus und machst es wieder an und dann ist es wieder sauber.
Gibt es da jetzt auch so Schadensersatzdinge, was passiert jetzt oder ist das eher so ein unter der Hand Ding?
Das Problem ist ja, dass wir im Endeffekt wirkliches Enforcement nur in den USA sehen. In den USA ist es halt so, dass der Gesetzgeber relativ klare Regelungen hat. Er hat die Möglichkeiten diese Regelungen auch zu verifizieren und er hat eine Justiz, die an der Stelle Zähne hat. In Europa ist es halt so, dass eigentlich ja jedes Land, was Automobilindustrie hat, ist betroffen und infolgedessen gibt es offensichtlich so eine Art Gentleman's Agreement, dass man sich da halt nicht zu sehr beißt. Der Herr Dobrindt hat mal versucht, Fiat anzupfeifen, hat Fiat ihm einen Brief vom Anwalt geschickt und gesagt, du tut uns leid, aber soweit wir wissen, bist du deutscher Verkehrsminister. Wir sind ein italienisches Unternehmen, die italienischen Behörden sind für uns zuständig. Wir kommen nicht zu dir, um uns von dir anpfeifen zu lassen.
Das ist ja fast wie Facebook.
Ja, das ist lustig. Also deswegen guck den Vortrag vielleicht nochmal. Es gibt ein paar Lacher zwischendrin. Es ist ein sehr trauriges Thema, aber ich denke, die Leute 30 Minuten deprimieren ist unfair. Also in Folge dessen sind ein paar sehr spaßige Dinge drin.
Und ist das, der Beschiss läuft aber sozusagen immer auf dasselbe? Es geht immer darum, dass diese Abgasregelung irgendwie aus, um oder falsch geschaltet wird?
Also im Endeffekt ist der Trick immer, dass du halt bei den definierten Prüfzyklen, das ist dieser berühmte neue europäische Fahrzyklus, English New European Driving Cycle, NEDC, dass du den eben erkennst, ob du das jetzt machst, weil du einfach sagst, ich bin da immer drin, bis ein Timer abgelaufen ist, oder ob du das halt geschickter machst, indem du sozusagen dieses Zeitgeschwindigkeitsprofil dir anguckst und solange das so ungefähr passt, ist es wohl so ein Prüfzyklus. Indem gibst du, was das System hergibt, das heißt, du schaffst es eben, deine Abgasstrecke unter die magischen Grenzen von 180 Milligramm NOX oder 80 Milligramm NOX je nach Euro-Stufe drunter zu drücken. Und wenn du eben nicht in diesem Prüfzyklus bist, dann machst du irgendwas zwischen, ist noch okay, bist total abschalten. Also es ist nicht so, dass die dann alles komplett abschalten und halt wirklich nur auf die Prüfung optimiert haben, aber die haben natürlich schon die Situation, dass sie zu viel von diesem Ad Blu verbrauchen, dass sie zu viel Partikel erzeugen, die dann den Partikelfilter dreckig machen und der muss dann ausgebrannt werden, also diese Regeneration. Wenn du das zu häufig machst, ist er kaputt. Also das ist eben so ein Lifetime-Problem. Und das heißt, du willst dieses Kaputt natürlich auf jeden Fall auch bei einem Vielfahrer hinter drei Jahre schieben, weil zwei Jahre, das ist klassischerweise Gewährleistung, ein Jahr Kulanz. Und das heißt, wenn dieses blöde Ding in einem Taxi oder in einem Vielfahrer oder im Verleihfahrzeug kaputt geht, dann bitte nach vier Jahren oder fünf oder so, aber nicht vorher, weil dann zahlt es nämlich der Kunde. Und auf diese Art und Weise möchtest du nicht zu häufige Regenerationen haben und deswegen darfst du nicht zu viele Partikel erzeugen und das sind so diese Probleme, weswegen das eben dann dazu führt, dass die Abgasregelung eben nicht mehr auf optimale Abgase optimiert läuft, sondern eben auf optimale Betriebszustände für den Motor, sodass der glücklich ist, dass er eben nicht zu früh kaputt geht.
Nach uns die Sinnflote, hauptsache der Motor ist schon lange ganz. Eine letzte Frage noch, du hast Bosch erwähnt, diese Steuerungselektronik, die da benutzt wird, die kommt ja nicht, die bauen die Hersteller ja nicht selber, die kommen von Dritt zu Lieferern. Jetzt gibt es natürlich zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder sagen die so, liefern wir euch da sozusagen eine Touring Complete Maschine aus, welcher Co drauf läuft, das ist jetzt überhaupt so gar nicht unser Ding, und die andere wäre ähnlich wie der Vortrag über das Management von VW, dass man sagt, naja entschuldige die bei Zulieferer, aber sozusagen, dass alle Hersteller das machen und du davon gar nichts wusstest, das ist auch so ein bisschen komisch. Wo stehst du da oder wie muss man das einschätzen?
Ja, das lässt sich so gar objektiv erklären. Es ist ein Brief bekannt, der auch der Presse geleakt wurde von Bosch, wo Bosch VW darum gebeten hat, sie von Haftung freizustellen, weil dieses Einbauen dieser Funktion eben nach Einschätzung der Bosch-Ingenieure und ich denke, die werden sich auch mit ihren Juristen beraten haben, eben geeignet ist, um beim Emissionstest zu betrügen. In Folge dessen hat Bosch eben den Brief geschrieben und gesagt, hier bitte stellt uns von der Haftung frei, wir machen das schon für euch, aber wir sind der Meinung, das könnte illegal sein. Wir wollen freigestellt werden. Hat VW dann eben nicht gemacht, hat sie nicht von dieser Haftung freigestellt und in Folge dessen müssen sie sich auch vor einigen Gerichten jetzt im Moment verantworten, eben auch als Beklagte. Die wussten das, das ist sicher, also einerseits sicher über diesen Brief, aber andererseits auch sicher so, wie die Automobilindustrie arbeitet. Diese Steuergeräte werden von Bosch entwickelt, da ist auch die Software von Bosch drauf und diese Softwarekomponenten, die da reingebaut werden, sind aber eine Bestellliste vom Hersteller, vom Fahrzeughersteller und die ist auch iterativ, das heißt, die arbeiten über zwei, drei Jahre zusammen, so einen Motor und ein Fahrzeug zu entwickeln und dabei fällt einem Hersteller auf, ach, das hätten wir gern noch und das hätten wir gern noch und das hätten wir gern noch und das bestellt man dann eben bei Bosch und die liefern das sozusagen Modul für Modul nach und jede Woche oder alle, alle Monat, je nachdem in welcher Entwicklungsphase es gibt, gibt es dann eine Softwarerelease und dann baut man das wieder in die Fahrzeuge ein, vielleicht die Fahrzeuge testet das und das ist eben so ein iterativer Prozess. Das heißt, die Bosch-Ingenieure wussten das genauso gut wie die VW-Ingenieure und genauso gut wie die von Fiat oder von anderen Hersteller.
Das ist ja schon relativ frustrierend alles, was du da erzählst.
Naja, es ist halt ein Zeichen dafür, dass das Betrügen in der Automobilindustrie halt an dieser Stelle durchgängig war. Das lässt sich historisch erklären. Die Prüfungsregelungen wurden eben sukzessive immer verschärft, weil die Politiker halt natürlich einfach für die Umwelt was tun wollten, weil das auch ein politisch attraktives Thema ist. Wäre es schon dagegen, was für die Umwelt zu tun. Aber sie haben das Handwerk halt nicht ordentlich gemacht, weil sie haben eben diese uralten Prüfzyklen. Also dieses Ding heißt NEDC, New European Driving Cycle, ist aber pur alt, das ist von der Konzeption her 20 Jahre alt und das haben sie halt nicht angepasst und deswegen fanden diese Automobilingenieure relativ flächendeckend, also nicht nur bei VW, sondern auch überall sonst, dass das halt so eine Art Optimierungsproblem ist. Das ist so ein Spiel. Man muss eben diesen Test schaffen. Dafür gab es sogar ein Begriff, das heißt Cycle Beating, weil Test Cycle und Cycle Beating ist also innerhalb der Industrie der Begriff für diesen Sport. Und der Sport ist halt irgendwann eben nicht mehr auf der legalen und auf der lustigen Optimierungsseite, wie ich klebe irgendwelche Lufteinlässe ab oder ich schraube den rechten Außenspiegel ab, weil in Deutschland nämlich nur der linke Außenspiegel vorgeschrieben war für ein Fahrzeugzulassung, kannst den rechten ja abschrauben, also weniger Wind widerstand. Also solche Sachen, das war, sag ich mal, borderline legal und lustig und naja, aber irgendwann ist es eben dann auch ganz klar ins Illegale gegangen.
Glaubst du, und das ist die letzte Frage, wirklich glaubst du, dass sich die Situation verbessert?
Ich glaube, dass die Strafen, die es in den USA gibt, einfach eine abschreckende Wirkung haben. Das ist jetzt so viel teurer, als es ordentlich zu machen, dass ein vernünftiger Manager, ob er jetzt gelernt hat, dass das illegal ist und dass man das einfach nicht tut oder ob er einfach nur dem wirtschaftlichen Druck folgt, das nicht noch mal machen wird. Aber in Europa haben wir das halt nicht und deswegen bin ich persönlich leider der Meinung, dass die Hersteller sagen werden, guck mal, ist ja nichts passiert und das nächste Mal, wenn sie in der Gelegenheit sind und die Aufmerksamkeit der Öffentlichkeit halt nicht so drauf ist, sagen wir mal, irgendwann in fünf Jahren oder so, wird es wieder Leute geben, die die Entscheidung fällen zu bescheißen, weil es gibt ja das Präjudiz, dass sie im Endeffekt nicht wirklich irgendein Problem damit gehabt haben.
Das ist eine hervorragende Aussicht, das Einzige Positive, vielleicht sehen wir uns dann wieder und sprechen im Chaosradio drüber. Dieter Langer, vielen Dank. First Lights von TESC, letzter Song für heute vom Chillhop Sampler im Chaos Gradio 230, wo wir nachhaltige Berichtbestattung ertreiben und mein VPN gerade abgestürzt ist. Oh nein, werde ich jetzt gehakt. Wir wollen ganz zum Schluss, zum Abschluss, man kann fast schon sagen des Kongresses noch mit einem derjenigen Leute reden, die daran schuld sind, dass das alles hier so stattfindet. Herzlich willkommen Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club.
Jeweils alle schuld von mir.
Moment mal, bist du nicht einer der Pressesprecher auch?
Ja eben, aber das ist ja, Pressesprechen ist ja labern und die ganze Arbeit machen ja andere viel mehr noch als die, die an Tag eins den ganzen Tag nur davon erzählen, was andere machen.
Wie viele Leute sind das denn eigentlich, die dir dieses Jahr geholfen haben? Von den Engeln, wie viele Leute sind hier, die nicht einfach nur ein Ticket gekauft haben und sich es gut gehen lassen?
Da würde ich eigentlich alle Engeln mit zuzählen und dann bist du locker bei über 2000, oder? Das Engelsystem hat doch irgendwann an Tag zwei die Registrierung geschlossen, ging nicht mehr, braucht nicht mehr. Vielen Dank, dass ihr helfen wollt, aber ist jetzt gut.
Einen Applaus für die Engel vom Chaos Communication Congress, bitte.
Man redet ja immer so davon, die Engel haben hier ein Ticket bezahlt und kloppen hier mitunter sehr undankbare Arbeiten. Die leisten diese Arbeit noch obendrauf, was der Grund ist, warum die Tickets so günstig sind. Weil wir so gut wie jede Aufgabe, die hier anfällt, von Leuten erledigen lassen können, die das freiwillig tun.
Also die kein Geld kriegen und ein Ticket kaufen.
Die kein Geld kriegen und noch dafür bezahlen. Sonst würdest du so eine Veranstaltung, die würde mehrere hundert Euro pro Teilnehmer kosten, wenn du jede Arbeit, die hier verrichtet wird, bezahlen müsstest. Ich finde das dann so geil, so Aufgaben wie Flaschen sammeln. Das ist total beliebte Engelaufgabe. Weil du kommst durch das Gelände, kannst die ganze Zeit rumlaufen, dir Dinge angucken und hast noch so einen großen Wagen dabei, kannst Leute aus dem Weg schubsen. Das heißt, eigentlich eine super Aufgabe, die beliebt ist. Normalerweise machen das Menschen ja nicht ganz so gerne Flaschen sammeln. Diese ganze Engelgeschichte finde ich eigentlich sehr beeindruckend. Das sind die Leute, die dafür verantwortlich sind, dass die Sache hier so stattfindet. Der Chaos Computer Club säht da nur so eine kleine Saat, glaube ich.
Aber das ist ja auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile, 33 ist die Nummer. Das Motto ist dieses Jahr Works for me.
Ja, das mit dem Motto ist ja immer so eine sehr schwere Geburt. Es gibt bestimmte Abhängigkeiten von so einem Motto. Man muss diese ganzen Klamotten bedrucken. Das ist ein nicht kleiner Druckauftrag, für den dann so eine Druckerei auch mal die Klamottenlager Europas leer machen muss. Die Kleidung für den Kongress wird nicht vollständig. Die holen das noch aus französischen und englischen Lagern. Auch so viel bestellen wir. Dafür brauchst du natürlich ein bisschen Vorlauf. Kannst du im Motto nicht im letzten Moment entscheiden. Das heißt, eigentlich bin ich fast derjenige, der immer am meisten, am schnellsten dieses Motto haben will, weil ich mich auch um die Koordination von Design und solchen Sachen kümmere. Und gleichzeitig dauert das immer so, bis man die richtige Idee hat. Und es kommen dann so Vorschläge und dann merkt man immer so die Zünden nicht, weil das richtige Motto, das kommt dann irgendwann zu dir oder zu uns. Und dann sagen irgendwie alle aus der Sofortsicht, ja stimmt, das ist es. Wir haben lange mit diesen Works von mir gebraucht.
Aber das sagen wirklich alle, keiner widerspricht.
Ach, irgendeiner widerspricht immer, die hat man ja überall, die Leute. Aber es ist auch ganz normal, es gibt einmal Leute, die widersprechen aus Prinzip grundsätzlich. Und es gibt dann Leute, die haben Argumente gegen dieses Motto. Eines der, ich glaube, das Kernargument gegen dieses Motto war, dass es wieder so eine, sag ich mal, ein negativ behaftetes ist.
Nämlich?
Auf der Suche nach diesem Motto habe ich dann irgendwann so einfach im Freundeskreis so ein bisschen rumgefahren, habe gesagt, sag mal eben Motto. Und wir wollten was haben, was so ein bisschen den Zeitgeist trifft und irgendwie auch richtungsweisend ist und viel Spielerei zulässt. Und dann kam über einen Kumpel von einem Kumpel, so irgendwie innerhalb von einer Minute die Antwort works for me. Und Begründung, weil das so ein bisschen den Zeitgeist widerspiegelt, dass Menschen sich immer mehr nur um ihre eigenen Probleme kümmern. Und Probleme, die anderen irgendwie ein Dorn im Auge sein könnten oder sind, und die man selber ändern kann, eben nicht gelöst werden. Und das ist genau in diesem Ausspruch des Programmierers, dem ein Bug reported wird. Und er sagt also, bei mir tritt dieses Problem nicht auf, oder ich kann dieses Problem umgehen, mich hindert es nicht an meinem Erreichen meiner Ziele. Und da es dein Problem ist, ist es meiner Aufmerksamkeit und Würdigung und Behebung nicht würdig. Und diese Geisteshaltung wollen wir ein bisschen vor Augen führen und natürlich kritisieren. Und dieses schon wieder entkritisierende Motto war eines der häufig vorgetragenen Argumente gegen dieses Motto, was aber glaube ich dadurch inzwischen enorm aufgewogen wurde, wie viel Spielerei dieses Motto auch zugelassen hat. Dank Stella, die das ja dann umgesetzt hat und halt irgendwie dafür gesorgt hat, dass wir einen Design haben und eine Gestaltung dieses Motto, die sehr zum Mitspielen auffordert und einlädt und das ist das, wenn du wirklich weißt, dass so ein Motto halt lebt und weiter lebt. Und deswegen bin ich damit total glücklich.
Sehr schön. Also von wegen schon wieder was kritisches und so. Es gab ja im Vorfeld des Kongresses auch so eine, ich weiß gar nicht, inwieweit die an die Öffentlichkeit, also eine breitere Öffentlichkeit getragen, sowohl geschrieben wurde ja drüber auch, dass es anscheinend auch zwei Lager gab, so zwischen, okay, was sollen diese ganzen Nicht-Hacker, Nicht-Programmierer hier, sind das nicht mittlerweile ein bisschen viele Leute? Ist das, also wenn ich die letzten Jahre so beobachte, ist ja das Konzept des Kongresses schon, kommt mal bitte alle und guckt euch das an, also wir kriegen nicht mehr alle rein, aber kommt mal im Prinzip alle. Und dann gibt es aber jetzt die Leute, die sagen, ja, make Congress great again, only detect people, ist das klein oder ist das sozusagen wirklich ein Schiss mal in der Community?
Also ich glaube, da draußen gibt es eine Nachfrage an Kongrestickets und die ist irgendwie um x größer als die Anzahl Tickets, die wir verkaufen können. Und jede Person, die jetzt kein Ticket bekommt, sieht da natürlich ein Grundsatzproblem drin, dass sie kein Ticket bekommen hat. Und dementsprechend, wenn das jetzt eine Person ist, die nicht zu dieser Community gehört oder die sich nicht als Teil dieser Community fühlt, die sich vielleicht jetzt nicht als Hacker begreift, dann ist das natürlich die Exklusivität, dass der Club sich abkanzelt gegenüber Neuen. Und wenn das eine Person ist, die sich als sehr groß als Teil dieser Community begreift oder als Hacker sieht und kein Ticket bekommen hat, dann ist das natürlich wegen den ganzen Neuen, die Neuen nehmen uns ja hier die Kongressplätze weg. Aber natürlich gibt es eine grundsätzliche Überlegung oder gibt es Leute, die sich die Frage stellen, wie kriegt man dieses Wachstum der Veranstaltung gesund hin, um einerseits den Kern zu bewahren und andererseits sie wachsen zu lassen. Und wir haben ja auch ein richtig krasses Wachstum hinter uns. Der 28C3 hat mit 3.500 Leuten in Berlin stattgefunden. Und wir sind dann auf 6, auf 9, auf 12. Also da gibt es ein Wachstum, aber gleichzeitig weiß ich, dass die eigentlich die Programmanteile, wie viel jetzt Security, wie viel Politik, wie viel Hardware Making, wie viel Science, Moment jetzt hab ich wieder einen vergessen. Also Polsak, Security Hardware Making, Science und Adenkulture, genau. Und Raumfahrt jetzt auch nochmal. Die Verteilung ist eigentlich immer gleich geblieben inhaltlich. Und wenn man dann jetzt liest, ja der Kongress ist jetzt irgendwie auf einmal politisch geworden, ja so ganz plötzlich ist der Chaos Computer Club aus dem Nichts heraus. Man erinnert sich an die völlig unpolitische Gründung in den Redaktionsgebäuden, der Taz und ein rein technokratischer Text, in keinerlei politische Dimension dabei gewesen. Und jetzt ist das hier auf einmal eine politische Veranstaltung geworden.
Also ohne das ganz abbrechen zu wollen, aber es gab schon Entwicklungen, oder? Also quasi der politischen Gründung war nicht schon sozusagen mal eine Phase, wo man gesagt hat, okay, da geht es jetzt schon auch mal eher darum, dass wir erstmal unter uns sind und zu gucken, was wir machen.
Das kann sein, dass es solche Phasen gab, aber da war ich wahrscheinlich dann nicht dabei. Vor deiner Zeit. Das muss vor meiner Zeit gewesen sein, ja. Aber klar, es gibt immer Leute, die sind dann unglücklich, wie sich Dinge entwickeln. Und es gibt immer Leute, die auch irgendwie was brauchen, um sich zu beschweren. Und es ist nicht so, als würden wir da nicht drauf genau hören und achten und diese Argumente abwägen. Niemand hat das Ziel, diese Veranstaltungen irgendwie anders zu machen oder zu verwässern. Aber man wäre doch auch bescheuert, so ein Ding hier aufzubauen und für sich zu behalten und zu sagen, nee, das ist jetzt gut, das wollen wir aber jetzt nicht, dass hier noch mehr Leute kommen und sich erfreuen an dieser schönen Welt, die wir hier schaffen. Das ist sehr bescheuert.
Du hast es gerade schon kurz erwähnt, dass es rumging, der Kongress ist ganz plötzlich politisch geworden. Ich habe das vorhin schon erwähnt, als Maha hier war. Ich habe gelesen, erstmals der Linguist auf der Bühne des Chaos-Kongresses, was nicht so ganz richtig ist. Was war denn deine schönste Presseanfrage eigentlich? Jetzt hier während des Kongresses oder im Vorfeld auch? Oder generell, wie erlebst du das denn? Ist das noch so, dass da jetzt kommen da jetzt die wohlgefährlichen Journalisten, die sagen, also hier Kongress, tolle Sache, wir berichten darüber. Oder kommt auch noch sozusagen dieses ganz neue, wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht, was hier passiert?
Kaum noch, also die Journalisten, die hier hinkommen, die sich dieses Themas annehmen, die haben ja auch einen Grund, warum sie das machen oder warum sie dafür ausgewählt wurden. Und die sind erstens der Veranstaltung sehr wohlgesonnen, weil sie das ja auch hier sehen. Also und davon natürlich auch angetan sind und sich freuen. Und eigentlich haben wir sehr selten so etwas wie eine, sag ich mal, böswillige Presse Anfrage oder so, das im Rahmen der Veranstaltung eigentlich kaum. Ich habe mich nur gewundert tatsächlich, dass, also ich muss das noch erforschen, irgendwie haben alle so, wie soll man das sagen, also diese Meldungsjournalismus, also ich will das jetzt nicht negativ meinen, sondern quasi so diese Charger, die morgens dann irgendwie so ein paar Gespräche, Tag, also es ist Chaos Communication Congress, das wird dann erwähnt morgens in einer Radiosendung, was weiß ich, WDR, Deutschlandradio, Deutschlandfunk, die reden dann kurz darüber und die haben alle die gleiche, die haben alle die gleiche Antext da gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, wo die den her haben. Wie war der? Ja, was weiß ich, in Hamburg trifft sich heute der Chaos Computer Club, Schwerpunkt der Veranstaltungen sind Fake News und Social Bots. Und das stimmt halt nicht.
Also falls jemand Zugriff auf einen DPA-Ticker hat, gerne mal danach gucken.
Ich glaube, das liegt an der DPA-Meldung, die da vor ein paar Tagen gegangen ist, wo dann eben auch gesagt wurde, wir wenden uns dem Rechtspopulismus relativ prominent zu und beschäftigen uns auch mit Fake News und Social Bots. Und wahrscheinlich hat einfach eine übergröße, eine höhere Anzahl von den Morgens-Meldungsjournalisten geguckt, so la la la la, ach das ja hier Fake News kenne ich. Und dann musste ich relativ viele Radio-Interviews zu Fake News und Social Bots geben und habe dann aber auch so ab dem dritten aufgehört, darauf hinzuweisen, dass es nicht wirklich der Schwerpunkt der Fahrt startet.
Aber das ist schon auch interessant, weil so wird ja dann eine Wahrheit auch gemacht, wenn genug Leute den irgendwann enervierten Pressesprecher fragen, sag doch jetzt mal, wie das ist mit den Social Bots. Was waren denn die Kernthemen des Kongresses, wenn es nicht Fake News und Social Bots waren?
Das ist so die Frage. Wir haben dieses Jahr echt Unglück gehabt, weil wir viele von den Headlinern, die man so eigentlich an Tag 1 haben möchte, an dem Tag nicht konnten. Und das sind dann Italiener oder Amerikaner, die irgendwie dieses Fest mit dem Tannenbaum in der Familie feiern müssen. Und dann können die nicht an Tag 1 da sein. Und ich fand zum Beispiel sowas wie... Weil ja Wahlmanipulation war ja ein großes Thema. Darum gingen die ganzen Presseanfragen vor dem Kongress. Dann haben wir natürlich mit Alex Halderman hier einen Wahnsinnsschwerpunkt setzen können in diesem Bereich. Ich glaube, das war so ein Schwerpunktthema. Und natürlich, klar, Rechtsextremismus. Natürlich haben wir nicht durch Zufall die NSU-Monologe an Tag 2 so prominent im Programm. Natürlich haben wir nicht durch Zufall Maha mit dieser Schwerpunktsetzung. Danach den Burschel und solche Themen. Natürlich ist das etwas, wo wir auch einen Schwerpunkt gesetzt haben. Aber es ist irgendwie schwer, wirklich so ein Schwerpunktthema zu nennen, weil das Security-Track-Team jetzt etwas ganz anderes sagen würde. Die haben natürlich mit dieser Malware, mit dieser Pegasus-Analyse und so das gemacht. Was war das? Das war ein Staats-Trojaner, der das Citizen Lab gefunden hat, der auf iOS-Hardware geht. Das war vor ein paar Monaten, dass der entdeckt wurde, der dann analysiert wurde. Das ist natürlich eine der krassesten Aktionen, wenn du einen Staats-Trojaner fängst, analysierst, auseinander nimmst, die Sicherheitslücken schließt, den Staats-Trojaner veröffentlicht und damit in dem Fall Dissidenten in irgendwelchen Demokraturen schützen kannst, die zum Opfer eines solchen Angriffs geworden sind. Das sind für mich absolute Highlights, die diese Szene hervorbringt im Laufe der Zeit.
Und das wäre auch jetzt dein persönliches Highlight, dann würde ich jetzt sagen, dass wir uns danach fragen wollen, was jetzt, wenn man es nicht allgemein sagen kann.
Es ist super schwer, ein persönliches Highlight zu finden, wenn man erstens das Programm gemacht hat und weiß, dass es alles Highlights sind, aufnahmslos. Ganz ehrlich, es ist keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute wir ablehnen mussten. Mit großen Schmerzen, wo du denkst, es ist fürchterlich, diesen Talk ablehnen zu müssen, aber er wird jetzt abgelehnt, weil gleiches Problem wie mit den Tickets, es gibt nur so und so viele Shorts. Also das erste ist schwer, wenn man sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat, jetzt nochmal ein Highlight rauszunehmen. Zweitens, wenn man so wenige Talks gesehen hat wie ich, weil ich kaum, ganz, ganz wenig dazu gekommen bin, Talks anzuschauen. Ich habe den Talk von Ray gesehen, Lockpicking in the Internet of Things. Der hat mich begeistert, nicht nur von der Vortragsart her, weil er das, wie wirklich wenige schafft, diesen Talk auch so. Einerseits ist es total krass, was die machen, andererseits erklärt er es aber auch so, dass es wirklich Leute, die sich nie damit auseinandergesetzt haben, trotzdem verstehen. Das war einfach ein runder Talk, wie man den beim Kongress gerne sieht. Der hat mich sehr begeistert, dieser Talk. Aber das war einer, der ganz wenige, die ich überhaupt gesehen habe.
Was dann noch bleibt, ist sozusagen, fangen wir mit der offensichtlichen Frage an, wird es einen nächsten Kongress geben?
Ich gehe davon aus, wird der größer? Also wenn man über einen größeren Kongress nachdenkt, stellt sich die, also es wird sicherlich ein bisschen größer. Aber wenn man jetzt so sagt, wenn man jetzt in Richtung 20 denken würde oder so, dann geht damit das Problem einher, dass man dann ja nicht wieder zurück ins CCH kann, wenn man das vielleicht wollen würde.
Kann man kurz sagen, das CCH macht ja zu, also sie planen 2019 wieder aufzumachen.
Aber wir denken dran, dass eine Architektur ein großes Projekt ist.
Ja, Elbphilharmonie, die Hamburger wissen, wie das geht. Also gibt es überhaupt schon einen Ort für nächstes Jahr?
Nein.
Gibt es noch gar nicht? Okay, also gibt es eine Stadt?
Nein. Also der Hintergrund ist ganz einfach der, wir sind noch mit mehreren Locations im Gespräch und in den Sondierungsgesprächen. Und es gibt vielleicht eine vorsichtige Tendenz zu der einen oder der anderen Lösung. Aber das jetzt zu sagen, wäre fürchterlich, wenn man noch keine unterschriebenen Verträge hat. Ja, also es gibt noch keine unterschriebenen Verträge. Das wird vielleicht irgendwann so, im März könnte es sein, dass wir das ansagen können und dann machen wir es natürlich sofort. Aber es ist weder sicher, dass es nicht Hamburg ist, noch ist es sicher, dass es Hamburg ist. Es ist leider noch total offen und man muss da jetzt leider einfach kurz die Zähne zusammenbeißen und warten.
Na gut, ansonsten noch Famous Last Words? Mein Kongress ist jetzt vorbei. Die Leute gehen jetzt wieder nach Hause. Was sollen sie mitnehmen?
Eigentlich sage ich immer, nehmt so viel wie möglich von dem mit, was ihr hier erlebt habt. Das wahre passiert ja nicht auf der Bühne. Das passiert ja im Zwischenmenschlichen, in dem, was man hier erlebt, die Leute, die man hier kennenlernt. Ich hoffe, dass das Mut macht für ohne Zweifel ein paar schwierige Zeiten, durch die wir in Europa und in Amerika jetzt irgendwie in den nächsten Jahren gehen müssen. Und deswegen bin ich so froh, dass wir hier diesen Zulauf haben, weil das hoffentlich ein bisschen Mut macht, dass man doch noch einen Haufen korrekter Leute hat.
Sehr schön. Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Vielen Dank. So, wir kommen dann zum Ende der Sendung. Ich möchte mich bedanken bei Mo und Danimo, die die Redaktion hier gemacht haben, bei Helena, die den Ton gemacht hat und beim Vogue für das Bild, das ihr sehen könnt. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, das war mein Chaosradio 2016. Und ich habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.